Yeah.
There's a lot of people listening.
A lot of folks look at you.
Look at it.
God bless you.
That you looking at me looking at you,
look at you or your yoga class.
Did Yoga class here for the first time in awhile.
I'll stretch down.
It's fucking hard to do,
but if you feel great,
you ever do it?
Yeah.
I kept falling asleep.
I swear to God I was doing at the west side.
Why New York?
I go with my wife.
I would always fall asleep.
You fell asleep in yoga because I was high.
I don't even know how that's possible.
Oh,
you and your lay lay down and just don't get up.
It's really a,
it's hard to do though.
I did.
I fell asleep a number of times,
but I mean it's hard.
The yogas hard to do.
Oh,
you have.
Maybe this wasn't that hard.
This was just like stretching and stuff.
I did hot yoga.
Oh no,
that's,
no,
no way.
As soon as you walk in,
you're sweating.
Yeah.
Don't know.
I like that you really,
it's good for you.
Really stretch out because of it.
But God damn like it takes a long time to stop sweating after you get out of
there.
I was sweating for like an hour and a half.
That just,
yeah.
Yeah.
Drink tons of water before.
Ton of water after.
But it's so hot in there.
I mean it's like,
I dunno how many,
a hundred plus degrees,
whatever the fuck it is while you're in there.
But it's drinking alcohol.
Must be a good buzz after that.
Yeah.
You'd probably die.
Nah.
Ice Cold Beer with a shout about it.
Come on Joe.
I shot of vodka.
You heard me?
Tough guy.
I don't drink vodka by this shot.
I'm more of a screwdriver toward sort of a drunk driver.
What do you my aunt,
like a little bit of an eerie.
The Tom Collins.
I haven't even,
I don't even know what a Tom got out either.
I just liked the name.
I know what a cosmopolitan is,
but I don't know what's in it.
But I know the broads,
like the,
um,
I'll have a cosmo and that's where there's a few drinks,
right?
That they're feminized.
For whatever reason,
those drinks became a woman's drink.
And then there's like vacation drinks,
like a Pina Colada.
Yeah.
If you're out with the boys,
you can't get high on them.
You get sick first.
Really?
Well that's sweet.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're going to get that.
He fucked up on those things.
Get a buzz and Pina coladas and that much ice.
You got a drink.
That's true.
But the ice is probably good for it helps to rehydrate you.
I'm back on the show us by the way,
back up,
back down and got back there and you're out.
I swear I'm never doing it again.
That's a danger being a comedian though,
because I set my alarm like one of them,
if I'm hung over,
I got to show it at eight o'clock.
I set my alarm for 6:00 PM yeah.
Whoa.
That's sad.
I mean it's ridiculous.
I mean like you got,
you know,
you've got kids,
you've got a life.
I got,
I'm stand up.
Nothing else.
I'm a clown.
I'm a verbal clown.
So the time between you go to bed at 6:00 PM all that spent sleeping well,
no,
but it's just roll over in pain and agony.
I lament my mistake for the night because the buzz doesn't last nearly as long
as the suffering.
That's true.
That's one thing,
like if you are willing to go through the buzz,
like if you're willing to go through the hangover just to get to that buzz,
that's a big,
but you don't see opposite.
Yeah.
You go to the buzz and then you get the hangover and I regretted it every time.
Like very few people would go through.
Like if you had it,
the only way to get drunk is you had to feel like shit for 24 hours first and
then you could drink.
Yeah.
Nobody would drink right now.
I just want,
as soon as you said the ice house was still there,
I thought to myself,
man,
you martinis.
It's for,
why'd you think that?
I don't know.
I just had the image of having a Martini before you went on.
What kinds of Martini?
Like a James Bond type shaken not stirred that kind of a little bit dirty.
A little dirty.
I like saying that to a girl,
a little,
little stinky,
uh,
grey goose,
extra draw.
And you know what actually dry means?
It's not really straight alcohol.
Oh,
okay.
That was the other thing is remote.
They put in them,
waters it down.
The little mic gives the more,
that's why it's called the Martini instead of a strictly as of October.
But basically they're either gin and vodka,
but everybody just makes him pretty much strong.
What's Vermouth?
It's like some kind of sweet liqour that's mixed with,
or you wouldn't drink it on its own.
Huh?
So you only drink it in a drink?
Yeah.
Like olive juice is goddamn delicious.
Delicious.
Especially in a nice Martini is good for the blood pressure too.
I'm sure.
Juice of salt.
Olives are very good for everything,
right?
Yeah.
Olives the fantastic for you.
The olive oil.
That's why all these Italians and French lifts along those poor fucking Greek
fucks.
Those people,
they live on that place where nothing else grows with that island.
They gotta eat olives and shit.
Rarely.
Oh,
it's hard.
Yeah.
The places where all of his grow like uh,
like people that are used olives as a staple in their diet.
It's very laborious.
I have an olive tree in my yard.
It's not easy getting all of out of that fucker.
Did you ever think you'd have an old tree geo where you grew up?
No,
I did not.
I didn't ask for it.
She was there when I moved in,
but it's a,
my dogs eat olives.
You don't need them?
Yeah.
Nope,
nope.
You don't just eat him.
I wouldn't have said anything that I grew,
you know what I mean?
I still go to the store.
Even if I had an orange tree.
Oh,
I have oranges.
I eat those lemons.
I eat those.
I,
I grow tomatoes and Kale.
I have a garden.
I grow with a bunch of different kinds of vegetables.
I eat them all the time.
Yeah,
they're good tomatoes,
especially you grossly fucking jam and tomatoes in your yard.
Tomatoes can be delicious.
I've never had a craving for Kale.
I never woke up in the middle of my baby.
We got any Kale.
I am.
It's always chips and soda.
Why is it always the bad stuff you crave?
I don't know,
but I want a good run.
Lately I came home from the comedy store last night,
um,
at you.
Duke killed,
destroyed.
And I said,
you know what?
I was thinking about eating unhealthy and I said,
ah,
I'm in a good run night.
Now I'm going to go to the fucking supermarket but get a bunch of fresh
vegetables and blend those fuckers up.
Yeah.
And I made a Kale shake at like one o'clock in the morning.
Well that's why I like those,
those juices that are,
it's all like gray,
green juice and stuff.
Cause that's the lazy way out.
But at least it's healthy.
Yeah.
That's a good place down the street from here I go,
it's called the juicy lady.
And uh,
they,
they have,
um,
you know,
you can just order them right there.
It's nice.
But just to just get fucking vegetables in your body.
So many people don't drink enough vegetables.
They don't eat enough vegetables.
It's like the number one problem.
I think that most people have,
they just don't get enough nutrients in their body and their body is forced to
make,
do you live a dull existence?
Like your mind is dull.
You know,
your body feels dull.
Hey,
a little too much salami so loud.
That's God's plan was if you really love it,
you're not going to live long.
Well,
I found this place,
uh,
it's called Bordeaux.
It's out in a Gora [inaudible] Gora hills.
I was just here the other day and they have,
um,
they,
they make their own shark tutoring.
How do you say it?
Charcuterie,
sorry.
Sharp charcuterie.
Charcuterie.
I Dunno.
There's,
you know,
smoked meats.
They make their own Salamis and hams and stuff like that.
Oh,
it was fucking fantastic.
When you find like someone who's an expert at that shit and they really know
what they're doing.
I'm going to bring the guy some bear meat,
have them turn it into Salami diva.
You're going hunting again.
Ooh,
yes.
Have you shot at bear?
Yeah,
I shot a bear.
Wow,
that's cool.
Come over,
eat some delicious.
I'm good.
I'll just stop it.
Isn't that tastes good man.
People love this idea of like people a bearish for a long time before
supermarkets were invented.
Well,
it's funny how we separate what's really good for us to eat and like,
it's okay.
Like chickens and you know,
there are certain things I like,
I wouldn't think of eating horse.
Hello.
I ate some horse in Montreal.
Montreal.
Uh,
there's this place called Joe beef is a famous restaurant.
Oh,
I know.
You know.
Yeah.
That plays fantastic.
Yeah,
that's great.
And uh,
they served as a beef two different times.
One time.
It was like a beef tar tar or excuse me,
not with you.
Where you went.
Yeah,
I think the night of the fight.
Hmm.
Maybe.
I'm almost positive we went there probably after that.
A great French kid.
The George Saint Pierre.
Yeah.
Most likely.
I've been there a bunch of times.
I probably took you.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
Did you eat the horse?
Did you have horse?
No,
no.
I went with Dunkin.
We had horse tar,
tar,
all ugly.
Raw horse going too far.
So good.
I hear the ponies.
Delicious.
I'm a donkey guy myself.
Um,
and we had a horse tenderloin,
you know,
but it's one of those things like,
you'd say horse to people and it's for some folks,
like there's a lady that lives in my neighborhood.
I would never tell her that I ate a horse.
She rides,
she rides her horse by my house every day and she's real nice,
you know,
doing let her know that I eat horse and then I don't eat.
I don't eat a horse on a regular basis.
Nobody they can.
It's too rich.
Donkey Cock is very,
is a delicacy that we served.
We served horse on fear factor was one of the biggest issues on the show.
Oh really?
Yeah.
As far as like as people complaining,
we serve People Horse rectums Oh my God.
Yeah.
And people are so
angry.
They were so angry.
Like we were so many calls and this is like,
you know,
the early days,
the fear factor was essentially before the Internet had a real voice.
You know,
it wasn't,
the social media aspect of the Internet hadn't really been created yet the way
it is now.
It was more of like,
um,
you know,
there was like a few websites and a few blogs and stuff like that,
but that Twitter presence,
the Facebook,
but you know,
the communities that existed,
they didn't exist like they do now.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
The world's changed with that.
It's amazing,
uh,
for the good end,
for the bad,
but more for the good than anything.
You'll help me get on that.
You got to get on and Dominic made it,
put my head,
I had a little guts before you,
he got to promote this.
I mean,
it's the best way because you think about all this stuff that we used to have to
do,
you know,
every time you would go on the road,
you'd have to show up days earlier and do all this press.
Like,
I think Ralphie may was still doing that up until recently where he would show
up at a town like weeks out and do press and then come back in the week of and
you know,
really try to get the word out that he was going to be there.
Press in Philly,
like I told you of the Atlantic City Gig next week.
Yeah,
the Atlantic city gigs.
It was a great Gig for you,
right?
Your,
that's your area.
You're going buys Tropicana next Saturday and it's 2000 people.
It's the most intimate 2000 theater I've ever been in in the house.
So they're just,
there are built in such a way like it's kind of an arc and so half of them are
kind of around yet.
It's really beautiful.
You work the AC it all.
Yeah,
I've done the Borgata a couple times but that's it.
Yeah.
I've never done the trop but the difference is the Borgata is a four wall,
so the,
so the casino's not as behind you as they are at the sans lip.
Regatta was good,
but the sands is great.
Not the sand,
Tropicana,
you know,
they always say the sands cause it's the best Gig I've had since the sands.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That was the first took place I've ever had.
Like imagine how cool that was,
Joe from me.
You know the feeling like I go there with share,
which is already a big deal.
My family and friends are there and then you know nothing like pleasing your
sister,
your mother,
people you love.
And then I get the headline in there and I got the headline and then he,
he had me headline when Whitney Houston couldn't make like a couple nights and
then he opened for her.
What a fucking nightmare.
You Open for Whitney Houston on?
My God she was,
she was late all the time and I'm up on stage,
you know,
and I sold,
I told the crowd,
I says,
look,
I'm not jerking you guys off.
I said,
I'm up here.
Not because I'm being self indulgent,
Shane here.
I said,
I ain't taking a bullet for her.
She Ain't here.
And then they started cheering.
I said,
and I'm not gonna leave you in the dark while she just hung out with them.
Well,
no,
I just stayed on stage,
you know,
I owe like 45 an hour.
I was supposed to 25 minutes,
you know,
and when you're pushing shit,
man,
I don't know.
She was probably doing coke and eating pussy out.
Dare you.
I can't even believe you said that.
Don't you know she has left us.
I know have some respect for the dead dom.
I rera back.
I take it back,
but if it's bad Karma,
I take it back.
I liked that part.
Do it go get eaten buzzy.
I never get to watch it at the very least.
I haven't either.
But I've eaten some about you.
Yeah.
You know the more
you actually know them,
Whitney Houston.
That was a weird one.
Right?
Because like when she was doing that movie,
my body guard and she was America's sweetheart.
I know.
And you know her and Kevin Costner when love and she was the superstar and she
had that amazing voice and fuck man,
she wasn't,
no,
she didn't have an amazing voice when I've worked with her though.
She was going down.
Oh really?
Look Coco.
Yeah.
She was tell you who is fucking great.
Was Natalie Cole really well,
the people I opened for,
she was fucking talented.
No Shit.
Did you ever do that stuff,
Joe?
No.
I never opened for a while.
I did some stuff for MTV where opened up for Bon Jovi wants and a hundred good
guys.
Did you get back with them?
Just said Hi.
They were very nice and now trying to think maybe one or two other bands.
I think I did.
I'm trying to remember,
but the Bon Jovi one was weird because it was a theater in the round.
It was the first time I ever did,
I'd hate,
it was very weird because there was all this musical equipment on stage two and
they asked me to,
um,
I was,
I was warming up the crowd and I was also supposed to get people to come closer
to the stage and they wanted me to just get attractive people.
They wanted me to just get pretty girls to come close.
You stay back.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Like there's no way to do that without being a ledge or creepy.
Fuck any girl.
Can you hear me?
What are you girls with the nice ais in the big tips coming?
Like,
wait,
what do you do to that?
I remember how I handled it.
It was a long time ago was you know,
early nineties when first Gig was a Joan Jett and a black card.
Oh yeah.
Shit Park Convention Center.
Oh Shit.
And the guy says to me,
uh,
you know,
40,000 people,
which was really a lot then I was just starting now you know the guy has to be
$250 goes to stay on as long as you can.
Right.
What does that mean exactly what it say Alexa?
Exactly what he said.
So I go up and I'm like,
dude,
remember that pinch a loaf bit.
I used to have dementia,
low of two cup of squat,
the roads I was doing that bit and half.
Do you want answers laughing?
2000 people left and the other 2000 we w we hate you Joan,
Joan or screaming.
Right.
And I was up there for less than like maybe two minutes and somebody taught us
just like a Dixie Cup top,
just you know,
look light piece of paper.
Oh they had to see was that and I was out of there and the guy goes,
you did great.
I go only on for two minutes because nobody lasts that long.
I know what the fuck the SVT and say,
hey,
you know,
it's a change of pace because the band's tuning up.
You could hear the band tune and bank.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's one thing that's weird about opening for bands.
They will tune up while you're onstage.
Well,
and that level yet,
I mean,
when I work with Sharon,
it was classy because she was the one that there was the,
by far the best job I ever had an opening for anybody because she knows she had
a great crowd.
She had transvestites and mothers with the grandmothers,
with their grandchildren.
The audience.
Yeah.
ECLECTIC.
If you know what the security told me,
if they ever saw a single straight guy alone,
a sing and he looks straight,
they would,
they would track him all night because no,
no guy along goes to a Cher concert of his straight.
Oh,
that's a gay guy dancing and happy.
No problem.
So if someone's going to be like a crazy stalker,
it's going to be a straight,
straight guy.
But she was fun though.
Yeah.
You enjoyed working with her,
right?
Yeah,
I really liked her.
Do you ever feel like a friendship with her?
Do you contact her?
I'm not anymore.
But you know,
she's,
she's very isolated.
Yeah.
She's a good person.
And you know,
she was like,
she,
she used to ask me about the world,
like she wasn't really in it because she wasn't really in it to go,
well,
what's it like and do you know,
she asked me about people and then one night we went to,
I said,
I talked her into going out in Montreal.
look,
why don't you drop the outfits?
Stop wearing a hat top hat and a cane.
I like,
maybe nobody will notice you shoot where
I could just fix her with the fucking tales.
Does [inaudible] back and forth on the reds.
And she,
uh,
you know,
so we got to an ice cream place and some like old guy go in and look with French
gun.
Hey,
aren't you the famous one?
What's her name?
And that's all she had to hear it.
He goes,
yeah,
get ever,
forget all,
what's your name?
So then now that validated that she can't go out,
you know,
but I have one guy,
that's it.
Yeah.
But we had a good time,
you know,
we stayed,
it was a funny thing in the casino.
We would meet when I like in the,
in the arenas I would do my act and they'd have a break and then she'd come up.
So we'd never see each other except when she had like a team prayer.
And then sometimes I was in that.
But um,
when,
when she's,
we would cross each other one night at her grandmother and grandfather were
there and she said to me,
she goes,
you just did a juice joke,
my grandparents there.
And I said,
and by the way,
your answers out and your grandfather's looking at it.
And she started laughing.
Well it was that one video she did where she was on like a battle ship turn back
in time,
I think it was.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Could turn back time show he got a little charity if I can find,
oh wait,
I'm on.
I like some sheriffs on.
Yeah,
me too.
What's that song?
Gypsies.
Tramps.
Santis the people of the town.
I didn't like half breed,
which was happening,
have prayed,
was not,
but I did.
I loved the,
the Bob Dylan Song should cover it.
She's on Goddamn Ball.
I really want to do this baby.
Be Friends with you.
She's riding a cannon without hair.
Jesus.
Hey Joe.
We put the uh,
the song on that.
Uh,
what is it called?
Itunes.
Itunes,
iTunes or youtube.
Yeah.
It's called the just to disappoint you further.
The one you played last time you were here.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Well you doing any music back when you were opening for these people?
No,
but I did one time.
It come out,
we were at Madison Square Garden,
but we weren't at the big room that we were doing the smallest 7,500.
See the pellet form where I used to box and she,
this is so funny.
I bet her how I got the good,
the band wants me to go out and bake playing a guitar and she was singing this
song.
Something about the something fire,
the wheels of Samsung.
And again,
I get out there and I'm playing.
I'm really playing that.
He's the guys behind the Scrim,
the real guitar players playing his ass off and I'm faking.
Like I'm planning,
she's at the,
and I'm singing with her on the song.
We get down on her knees and we're like looking at each other and singing and
screaming and then I get off and she never said a word about it.
She never said,
what the fuck are you doing?
That was great.
That was going to be,
they work with her for all those years.
She would notice that this was day.
What was the song?
Oh,
he's saying I forget,
but it was pretty lucky.
It was a good rock song.
You know,
there'll be something like gimme shelter or something like them looking up the
oh wow.
But now how many different gigs did you do?
Whitney Houston?
Just the weekend.
It was a little long weekend and I think I opened for her three to three nights
and then it was like a long,
like a hot,
like Memorial Day,
July 4th something like that.
And then I,
I did a,
my own headlines.
The first in my headline was on the fourth night and I did a whole bit about
her,
like make fun of her and,
and singing and stuff.
And then the crew was crying often.
That's hilarious.
And her father was such a good guy and he,
I felt like he said to me,
you know,
I really look you,
you,
you're,
I said thanks.
He goes,
let me get a little work with my daughter again.
I said thank you.
And I'm thinking,
no fucking way.
I'd rather be at Jimmy's clam bar on bail for them before they shucked the clams
have them shocking in the back on clack,
clack,
clack.
But anyway,
it was that bad,
Huh?
Yeah.
You know shit like I remember saying on stage,
cause you know that she's always doing the prayer and looking,
Jesus does in his head.
Like,
you know,
I don't,
I know a lot about religious history,
but I don't think Jesus had 300 pound bouncers pushing old people away.
You know?
I mean she pushed people away.
Well,
you know,
I'm exaggerating kind of shit that had the divas thing that I couldn't stand
for.
The diva shit is weird.
Right?
Yeah.
I remember though,
read this article about Gene Simmons was dating Diana Ross.
Wow.
That's weird.
Yeah,
it was real weird.
It was way,
way back in the day and uh,
he just couldn't take the divas shit apparently.
Just couldn't take her being mean.
Those people.
Yeah.
Like that was the argument that they'd got.
But you know,
obviously this is like completely third hand.
Remember in the Millennium Millennium when Barbara Streisand,
uh,
did the MGM grand and if you remember that now,
well,
the funniest part,
what being held,
we were also connected.
A friend of mine's brother was a waiter at the MGM and he would bring her room
service and he was,
it wasn't allowed to look at her.
Why?
So he had the back into the room with the tray,
with the cart and just walk away and not look at her.
Is that hilarious?
This is Barbara Streisand.
Yeah.
I have a friend who,
um,
was told the exact same thing.
He was a stage hand and he was told do not look at her,
do not.
I talk to her and he violated it.
He uh,
you know it said something to her like Ms Tracy and your cue is going to be
done.
And she goes,
why is he talking to me?
Wow.
She pointed to him when she looked away and pointed to him and said,
why they so sweet when they're talking about their charities and all this
bullshit.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's without the diva thing is a very weird thing that did that getting above
everyone where you wanted to be treated like royalty.
There is a ballet dancer named Rudolph Noriev ever hear him?
Okay.
So he,
I used to park cars at the river cafe in Brooklyn.
Did you fuck them?
No,
I got,
it seemed like one of those guys,
the second base,
I got to crack the crack second base to a guy who was different than just a lot
of guys get second based on each other.
It's really no big deal.
I'll grab a tit.
I was hoping you'd go with it cause I didn't know what it meant.
But he used to come in and I like,
he was on of those guys with the Cape and everything and I,
he fucking hated me because I called him Rudy,
you know rural painted you.
Yeah.
Go Hey Rudy and how's it hanging?
I said,
cause I would always ask him questions about jumping,
you know,
I said,
could you dunk?
I see you could probably touch the room with you foot.
And he would never thought I was funny at all.
It was such a wise is super serious.
Oh yeah.
Shipper like talk about the male diva.
The ballet.
Yeah.
It's my life.
I danced,
I practice,
I spin,
I saw for the and I'm free.
I'm free.
Yeah.
I mean I'm all for people taking themselves seriously in small doses.
And you're doing important stuff like brain surgery.
Yeah.
You want that to be serious.
And buddy you wearing tights was wearing tights,
chatted,
drawn to the catch line.
One thing you don't want to hear your seat or your shirt,
your surgeon say,
has anybody seen my lucky scalpel?
You know,
we did,
we did a doctor Katz in the Austin.
Texas was a lot of fun.
How's he doing?
He's all right.
He's like,
you know,
I saw him in a hotel completely randomly and he was in a wheelchair.
Yeah,
he got up and did stand up though.
He stood up for that.
Which,
what is wrong with them?
What's called Mesh?
Yeah.
You know Jonathan Katz was the open mic host the first time I ever went on stage
at Nick's.
No stitches.
Oh no kidding.
Yep.
Yeah.
He was the host very first time.
Everyone on stage.
Wow.
Yeah.
I didn't know that was your first night.
That's such a nice car.
Yeah.
That place used to creep me out.
Cause you had,
when you walked to the back that had the wall was so thin,
so I was afraid it was just going to close up on me.
So you started with Paul,
Paul,
Paul Barkley and those kinds of yeah,
Paul was doing,
staying where the connection,
they were at the connection.
Paul Barclay,
the common connection
with Billy Downs.
Yeah.
And I was doing Nick's comedy stop and I was doing that,
was doing that.
I was doing a connection and I was doing stitches but I started out,
my first set ever was at stitches.
That was on a,
I think it was uncommon have at the time common ones.
There's two,
there's two locations for stitchers.
There was one that was right next door to the paradise,
which was a a rock club or saw Jerry Seinfeld perform there once and then a they
moved to another location where it was just autonomous.
It was just by itself.
And you connected to,
that was the first time I ever saw somebody get hit in the face with a bottle.
Oh No,
we go,
who is that?
Well actually the only time I've ever saw anybody get hit in the face with a
bottle just,
I wasn't involved.
I was just a,
I just happened to be there and these two guys were arguing in a bar and he
didn't even seem like they were arguing that much and it didn't get like crazy
or heated and this guy just smashed this kind of faced with a Heineken bottle.
Fucking blood was everywhere.
It was crazy.
I just couldn't believe someone could just smash somebody in the face of the
bottle so easily.
I'll never forget that because it just made me,
it made me realize like there's certain people out there that are already at
nine,
you know you might be at zero,
you walk into a bar,
you're like,
hey,
how's everybody doing?
What's up?
How are you?
Yeah,
I'll have a Martini extra dirty.
That's how you like it.
And then for whatever reason your elbow touches some guy,
he spilled his drink a little bit.
Whatever the fuck it was.
I don't know what happened.
I didn't see it.
I mean,
I was,
I was a good distance away in a crowded bar,
but I just happened to look over as these guys were exchanging words and I saw
that guy bottle,
that guy in the face.
I was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
The whole Bora mentality,
the guys that will get in a fight because somebody bumps into them,
you're going to get bumped into it.
Really.
Crowd.
Yeah,
I will.
If someone bumps in,
you know,
they say sorry,
and that's the end of it.
No matter what happens,
if you get fucking wet,
it's like,
didn't nobody did 99.9% of the time.
Nobody's meaning to do that,
but that this,
the,
the ability to bottle somebody in the face like that.
I mean,
that guy was scarred for life.
There's no question about it for nothing.
Nothing.
I never,
I was never in a flight and a board.
The only fights I've ever been in,
they were all about sports.
They're all plans.
Oh,
during a game.
Yeah.
I've seen that.
They used to have this,
uh,
thing in Boston,
this comics a baseball game,
like a softball game.
Every Monday I think it was,
and we'd all get together and uh,
the fucking heated screaming matches.
I would watch these comic to get into fucking out,
fucking out.
I was like,
God dammit.
You're playing softball,
right?
This is a comedian softball game.
I remember Brian Frazier and this other guy,
Matt,
which is in each other's face,
fucking screaming and spitting each other.
It was just madness.
Yeah,
probably.
They probably would be.
If one guy did something that touched the other guy,
they probably would have beat each other's brains out right there.
They probably have fought to the death over fucking softball over whether
or not a guy's foot had touched the bag before or after the other guy had caught
the ball.
That was a big dispute.
Joe could be.
It could be scrabble.
If you guys are feisty,
they're feisty.
Well,
that's what's dumb about it is like there's nothing on the line here.
There's nothing on the line.
This is not professional.
It's not even amateur.
It's not organized.
Nobody gives a shit if anybody wins or loses that.
There's nothing that's worth that.
My,
my little cousin who,
thank God he went to Rehab,
we're walking down the street.
I do,
I was doing helium in Philly.
You ever did a club glove,
that club yet woken down and these,
these street kids are waiting for this homeless guys in a sleeping bag to fall
asleep.
Cause some people had laid money on him.
So my cousin all of a sudden is going to be the hero.
Right.
And they were all,
uh,
and the guy said to me,
he goes,
listen man,
get your boy out of here.
All fucking murder him.
And I'm sure he was,
he was holding a piece or something.
You know what I mean?
But like I tell you,
cousin,
I don't understand the good they were.
They were waiting for the guy to fall asleep.
Take one.
No,
just waiting for him to,
you know,
they were going to take them with the money.
The people that put out on his chest when he,
you know,
he was a homeless guy and there were three just bad fucking dudes.
Three o'clock in the morning.
I said to my cousin,
there's nothing you can win from this.
You want to protect him?
Call the cops.
Don't get yourself involved.
Jesus Christ.
Stupid thing getting me killed.
Getting it.
You know,
for nothing you can run into the wrong people.
I mean,
not that that is the world of nightlife of cities and the p and the people that
are most dangerous or the ones that got nothing to lose.
Yeah.
Or they don't even realize they have something to lose.
They're not even thinking.
You know,
there's a lot of people that just not planning ahead or they think life is some
fucking movie.
They're going to pistol whip somebody and that's going to be the end of it.
And many times you seen a movie,
it got crack.
Somebody over the back of my head with a,
with a piece.
The guy goes down a wakes up an hour later.
Oh yeah.
But,
and then he's getting a bunch of fights.
Movies of the [inaudible] said that fighting is such bullshit as you know.
First of all,
hardly anybody gets knocked out.
Yeah.
Everybody,
everybody gets knocked out in Westerns.
One Punch a girl,
ducks and man,
you know?
You know what I mean?
It's like and fights.
You're slow,
slow,
real fights in real life or a couple of quick punches and people grab people.
You know what I mean?
Most of Pfizer,
just a sucker punch.
I've seen some fights last a while,
but not usually.
You know what I mean?
And hope I like a lot of times people are basically [inaudible] down deep there
pussy,
so they want to have a fight that's broken up immediately.
Yeah.
What's always shocking to me is when I watch people fight and they don't know
how to fight.
Like you got in a fight and you don't even know what you're doing.
Like I'm terrified to get into a fight and I've been doing it my whole life.
Yeah,
because you're smart enough to know how bad it is,
but I just can't imagine someone would just not have any skill at all.
Like I have no idea what to do.
And somehow or another you find yourself,
fuck you bitch and you're throwing crazy punches.
You're out of gas almost immediately.
Like,
what have you risked your life on?
You've,
you've taken this crazy like,
you know,
it's like you don't know what you're doing.
It's like getting on stage and playing guitar when you don't know how to play
guitar.
Right.
You don't know what you're doing.
Like what are you doing?
You're fucking crazy.
Like that time when you get onstage.
What if they had given you a real guitar and you had to play and sing?
We share
that.
I couldn't do anything the fuck they play in chords from Norwegian Wood.
Do you play any musical instruments now?
No,
I just,
I,
I play a little bit of guitar but I'm left handed so I rarely in unless I have
one in the house,
but I'm not any good.
Oh,
you have to have a different kind of guitar for the left where it's completely
opposite the string.
It's string differently.
So do you have it strong upside down?
That's what it is.
Yeah.
There are some,
I think they make like that Mccartney is lefthanded and I used to watch him play
bass and when you see those guys that would have like two and three next.
So their guitar,
is that like a fad does that out?
I didn't know what that I,
to me it's like so coolio led Zeppelin,
Jimmy page used to have that,
but I don't even know what it does.
I guess they,
you know what?
Probably they have a different chords.
The frets are different,
so they have like different chords already set up so they can go back and forth.
I'm imagining that that's what it is.
Yeah.
I'm imagining too,
I've been on a Hendrix kick the last a few weeks.
Great.
Any,
oh,
he said,
well,
I mean I've always been a huge fan.
I mean that's the why I renamed the show the Joe Rogan experience.
Oh yeah.
Some reason why.
Yeah.
I mean look right behind me,
Hendricks,
I'm a huge Hendrickson.
Was he arrested for heroin?
Toronto hollow.
He was trying to take it into the country.
Yeah.
Whoops.
That's a good mood.
Somebody should tell him he was left handed as well.
Yeah,
so I'm going to tell him this.
Heroin and Toronto,
I was his left hand.
Uh,
Kurt Cobain was left in,
you know,
there's a high instance of a lefthanded genius.
A lot of left hands.
Are you,
you live genius.
Lefthanded people are oftentimes,
you know,
one thing that left handed people apparently excel at is fighting.
It was like a,
um,
a study done on lefthanded people.
They were trying to correlate lefthanded people with violence.
They were trying to say that lefthanded people,
um,
perhaps or more violent or better at violence.
They couldn't make that correlation.
This is from a radio lab podcast.
But when they did,
what they did figure out is that lefthanded people are better at fighting
because one of the reasons is they're doing everything the opposite where,
so it confuses everybody.
Well,
my father was a boxer and he taught me to start right handed if you know,
if I was ever sworn it like summer camp and then switched lefthand that he said
that confused the fuck out.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Lefthand is weird because the jabs coming from the wrong side.
You're expecting a jab from over here and it's coming from over here and then
the left hand is the big weapons to the right hand.
It fucks you up unless you're used to it,
but you got to get used to it.
Like some guys,
they would always have their toughest fights against south paws,
like they would do great against Orthodox fighters,
but they can never get their rhythm against south pause.
Did you watch the fight?
Yeah.
I'm one of the few people that liked it.
You like to see?
I don't like it.
I loved it.
I enjoyed every minute of it.
I thought it was a fascinating fight.
Why?
Because you know some,
there's so much more about the martial arts and boxing and stuff.
To me,
I wanted to see a fight,
not a boxing match.
You know like I wanted to see anger.
There was no anger,
nothing.
Did you see Canelo Alvarez,
James Kirkland the next week,
the one that knock out,
I saw the knockout while I was fucking good.
Curoil,
you see that look on his face when he was out on his feet down.
Canelo Alvarez is a fucking beast.
He's a bad mother fucker.
But his style is the style.
That's the Mexican kid,
right?
Yeah,
the redhead.
Redhead.
Yeah.
Handsome Fella.
His style is the kind of style that everybody really wants to see today.
Like Gennady Golovkin like seek and destroy destructure son,
Floyd Mayweather is not that guy.
Floyd Mayweather is a wizard.
I mean he really is a magician in there.
Oh,
he's smart.
He's not getting hit and he's defensive and his counter punching.
But you know like because of the stuff that you're involved in,
I got more used to exist,
like action.
You know what I mean?
I know they get locked up sometime on the floor for too long,
but it's still,
it's pretty funny when even they're locked up and the guy just pounding the
other guy's temple.
Well,
there's more variables in MMA and that's what makes it more exciting because you
never know what the fuck's going to happen.
You never know if guys gonna kick you or take you down or try to submit you or
punch you.
There's just so many different things going on and there's so many different
things you have to think about and prepare for and so many different angles that
a person could take when things aren't going their way,
you know?
And that just doesn't exist in boxing.
When you're a guy like Manny Pacquiao and you're fighting a guy like Floyd and
Floyd's got you figured out after the first round,
good luck.
You know,
you're only locked.
He did.
The best case scenario is you land a really good left hand and then you follow
up with a combination.
And he tried to do that a few times,
but Floyd just went into that defensive shell and just shook his head at I'm
nopal didn't do a nope,
you didn't hurt me.
You know,
he's just the best ever.
I,
you know,
a lot of people give me shit about saying that.
Like I had an argument with Max Kellerman about him when he was like,
sugar ray Robinson is the best ever.
You know,
how could it be the best ever sugar ray Robinson lost to Jake Lamata you telling
me that Floyd Mayweather would lose to Jake Lamata I'm telling you out of your
fucking mind,
Floyd Mayweather would box circles around Jake Lamata if they were the same
size.
The Jake [inaudible] is,
is great and tough as he was,
would never fucking come close.
You look at what Floyd Mayweather has been able to do.
Two murderous punchers like Canelo Alvarez and all these guys that just smash
everybody else.
I can't even touch him.
He barely can get close to him.
He's a wizard is,
it was I,
I take my hat off to them.
You know,
you know Angela,
the sure he used to come and see me in west palm all the time and he knew that,
you know,
my,
I had like some history of boxing and my family and he brought me this great
picture of all the Philly fighters and I was,
uh,
at the,
at the dinner with him one night as I started picking his brain a little,
I said,
who is the baddest motherfucker bowl?
So said,
who do you think of all the guys that you saw or were,
could beat anybody?
He goes,
Sonny Liston,
hands down.
Wow.
He said everybody was afraid him.
He said,
you know,
he was,
yeah,
a lot of problems,
but whatever.
I don't know what mob ties.
Yeah.
But apparently heroine and you know,
that second Ali fight was definitely thrown.
Oh yeah.
You know,
you could say it's such a joke to fan.
He's faking.
Well,
he got punched like they call it a phantom punch is not a fan of punchy.
Definitely got punched.
But he was waiting for the first punch to land so that he could just lay down,
like,
pull that up,
Jimmy.
We go watch this.
It's a Muhammad Ali versus Sonny Liston too,
in Lewiston,
Maine.
You know,
I thought it was going to be foreman because of his size and his strength,
but he,
you know,
he's the list.
It was the toughest.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
foreman before Ali beat him was a different animal post Ali.
He was never the same guy because that air of invincibility was gone.
And then he had that crazy fight.
I believe it was with Ron [inaudible].
They just fucking blasted each other in the head and knocked it down like four
or five times.
You remember to punch that he hit a George Foreman with in Jamaica.
Picked him up.
Not your children,
Joe Frazier.
Frazier.
Yeah.
Pick them up on a stomach punch.
I don't remember what,
what he hit him with,
but I remember his legs literally came up off the ground.
I never saw that before.
Yeah.
Credible.
He was a monster.
He was such a fucking murderous puncher.
I was at the Spinx a Tyson fight.
Uh,
Michael Spinks.
Yeah,
we talked about those couple of times on podcasts.
How scary he said up jumped the devil.
Yeah.
That's really what we,
I think we talked about it at the laugh factory.
I think we talked about it more than once.
Uh,
because it was such a,
I mean,
you were there for like one of the most stunning moments in boxing history.
That was cool.
A lot of people talk.
Michael Spinks was going to give him a hard time cause Spinks had gone 12 rounds
at Larry Holmes and you know,
and beat Larry Holmes by decision and you know,
and he was the light heavyweight champion.
He was a good boxer.
He just had no business.
He was so small too.
He was barely one 99 you know,
and he's fighting Mike Tyson.
Tyson was,
Tyson was a much bigger,
you know,
in comparison to today's fighters.
He was probably like two 20 built better though.
It's compact and 1965 Lewiston,
Maine,
watch this because Ali still look and slick man.
There's still to this day,
no heavyweight that moves like him.
Man,
I got fucking good.
He moved
so light on his feet for a guy who's 220 pounds or whatever the hell he was,
side to side,
all that head movement.
You mean you can't look at that.
You can't keep in touch him listed with lunch four with that Jab.
Good luck.
Now here he gets some with the punch like right as he tries to listen,
tries to crowd them and it happens with Ali's a face to the camera.
So listings back to the camera and he just comes with an overhand right.
And as soon as he catches,
listen on the draw,
listening goes down like he got shot.
I think it's right here.
Right here
since whenever it is.
It's when listings backs to you.
Oh,
but look how beautiful Ali moves man.
It's amazing.
I mean he really did float and this is the real Ali.
This is Ali of 1965 you know before the army and all that.
Yeah man to army fucked him.
That whole thing fucked him because for three years from 1967 to 1970 he was
completely out of committed shed is total prime.
Yeah,
look,
watch.
We'll show the difference here.
Like when,
when he finally catches like listen,
even though listens moving towards him,
he doesn't even live at,
he's trying to hit him.
I wonder if they had like a,
they gave him a time where you had to get knocked out too.
I mean,
it must be probably the first raveling cause all the gambling on it.
Oh yeah.
I mean that was everything.
Here it is.
Boom.
Right there.
I mean that this is the fucking way.
There's is no fucking way.
They look well shit.
The way he's going down,
the way he gets up.
Oh look,
you fake.
He could see him thinking I should probably fall down here.
And he gets up finally and Jersey.
Joe Walcott as a referee to I believe.
Yep.
Yeah,
that's true.
Walcott
and something happened there and now Ali's is tuning them up and they stopped
the fight.
That's it.
So I guess it had reached a 10 power.
Got that.
He got up after that.
Yeah.
Here's the knockout in slow motion.
What?
I mean,
he does hit them.
Everybody calls it the Phantom Punch.
But watch this punch.
He definitely does hit him as listing moves forward.
He does.
Boom.
See?
Yeah,
clean hit.
No doubt about it.
He definitely tagged him,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't the kind of punch that would put a guy like listing out.
It'll probably stun him,
but I just,
it did.
I didn't,
I
believe that that was a real one.
Punch knockout.
Now watch that and I'll watch,
uh,
he came back against,
the white dude,
a Jerry quarry.
Sure.
If that was his,
that was his comeback fight.
Mohammed Ali versus Jerry Quarry.
And when he fought Jerry quarry,
this was in after he had taken all that time off and his body just looked
different.
Man.
He just like,
Jerry Corey was like a really tough guy who by the way before he died,
couldn't even figure out how to walk.
Like you couldn't figure out where he was.
Didn't know where his underwear it was.
Yeah,
he was gone.
He was,
he didn't know,
couldn't give you walked out his front door.
He never make it back inside.
He was just gone.
You know,
Holly's talking to him here,
but if like,
if you look at Ollie's body,
like as Ali goes back,
the thing about Ali was that if he wasn't training for a fight,
he wasn't working out.
So he didn't spend those three years lived in weights and running hills and
fucking hitting the heavy bag.
He wasn't doing anything.
I mean he's probably just,
just fighting to keep from getting locked up in jail,
you know.
But if you look at his body like look at it,
he's all smooth and there's no muscles like looking at him.
He looks like shit.
I mean,
he doesn't look anything.
He used to look,
I mean he's,
he's bouncing around a little bit in the beginning,
but he's just not the same guy.
They still had some pretty big fights at the end.
Yeah he did.
But he was never the same guy and never forget that Larry Holmes trying to get
the rough to stop the fight cause they didn't want to beat them up anymore.
That was awful.
His idol,
that was awful because that was after Ali had no money left and he was really
suffering from Parkinson's already.
He was,
yeah,
I was already kicked in.
He was already,
uh,
in really bad shape.
We,
you know,
as a friend of mine,
we used to work at a,
as Dorman together and doc Watson's affiliate was Randall Cobb tax Cobb.
And we saw him take a beat and from homes.
Yeah,
we were just going go down Randall,
go down.
Yeah.
Fucking horrible.
That was the fight that made Howard Cosell retired from boxing.
I remember that.
I'm done no more.
Look at that little monkey run
our code sal who called like some of the greatest fights of all time.
But like if you look at Ali here,
I mean he's still looks good,
but it's just not the same.
Molly,
just not the same guy.
He just,
his body doesn't look the same.
He smooth.
I mean,
granted he's had three years off,
but he's just,
I mean the,
the old Ali go now to Ali versus Cleveland Big Cat Williams.
And I've always said,
if you want to look at it like Ali in his prime,
when Ali was in his prime,
his,
when he was fighting this guy,
Cleveland Williams and Cleveland Williamson is this big fucking scary murderous
puncher and Muhammad Ali box,
this guy's fucking face off.
Who was the one that he,
uh,
when he was doing,
what's my name?
What's my name?
Oh,
I'm shit.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Cause the guy wouldn't,
clay called them cut color and Cassius clay.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
What's my mean?
I forget who that was.
God Damn.
I'd have to look at his rhetoric,
but Cleveland,
he's like,
look how muscular Williams is.
Mo Williams is a fucking animal murderous puncher and he just could not catch
Holly.
This is Ali and his prime.
This is Ali,
like in 67 he says this,
he goes,
oh,
but the movement decide,
decide.
It was like there was no fucking heavyweights that ever moved to like that.
No one.
I mean he literally moved faster and lighter on his feet then most welterweights
and he was fighting at 200 plus pounds.
I mean,
I don't know what he weighed in his prime.
It's probably probably like two 20 or something like that.
You ever see that picture of him in the Beatles?
Uh,
which one?
Classic picture.
Just name it.
The Beatles in Miami.
Just a funny thing.
I'm trying to find out who that guy was that did that.
I know I came with my knee early careers.
Got a bit of a process.
Cleveland.
Oh,
the hair?
Yeah.
They all used to like that.
Sugar Ray Robinson had that too.
The conk,
they would call it.
But you know who also is great sugar ray Leonard.
Oh yeah,
dude.
It was in front.
Why?
Just shut it off Jamie.
Keep that shit on son.
I'm trying to find this guys name.
Jamie.
Hey Jamie is good over there.
Look at them.
Sexy Bitch.
Um,
see Motherfucka Jimmy Ellis.
Jimmy Ellis.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
Wow.
Pretty sure.
Pretty sure if Jimmy Ellis did he deal with I was sparring Pete and two it
probably was,
that's probably what happened.
Would knock him out cause he was so my editor just beat his ass.
I'm almost positive was Ellis.
I'm sure somebody will curve back to me if I'm wrong,
but if you,
um,
you watched his fight,
this in my opinion was like the quintessential Ali and this was,
I believe the last fight before he went away.
Um,
they just had never seen anybody like this guy before.
He do.
In those three years did he wasn't in prison?
No,
I think actually I think he fought.
They fought two more times and then he went,
yeah,
he fuck Ernie Terrell.
And then Zara Foley,
um,
he went to,
uh,
you know,
he had to fucking go to court and they look at this,
God damn,
he was fast.
Look at this,
the legs,
pap,
pap pap,
and then out of there,
I mean he was,
he was barely getting hit back then,
man.
It was so fucking quick.
And then you see like his later fights,
like when he fought Joe Frazier,
like rumble in the jungle and you know,
there was this,
it was so much slower afoot.
Probably had knee problems by then.
And you know,
he took a beating from Frasier.
I mean they took a beating from each other.
Oh,
those were horrendous fights.
Those are her rent renders,
fights.
His daughter told me that may amaze a friend of mine,
his daughter,
and you remember him reading shore.
She was always at the store.
She's a comic,
right?
Yeah.
I used to,
I remember the first time I brought her up and I said,
oh no,
she brought me up and I said,
maybe in La.
I said,
I always,
I was thinking,
thinking in the back,
I wonder if I could beat Ali's daughter and if fight,
I probably know.
Yeah.
Well definitely not the other one that Laila Laila skewed Gary Too.
She'll beat the shit out of yeah.
Beautiful.
And to beat your ass may amazing an example of how a woman could be pretty and
look like her father.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
he's got a son too that comes around the comedy store or used to come around the
comedy store back in the day.
I don't remember the yeah.
May May uh,
introduced me to him one day and I was like,
Whoa,
this dude looks exactly like Muhammad Ali.
It was crazy.
And you know,
at the time he was fairly young.
The kid,
you know,
this was like,
I want to say 10 years ago maybe,
but Cleveland Williams was like this like perfect style fighter to show like
Muhammad Ali in his best.
Like he just wasn't there,
man.
He just wasn't there.
It was just not nearly as quick.
Oh Man.
Like,
look at this,
look at that.
That's insane.
He was so slick and he just redefined what it meant to be a professional boxer.
He introduced a whole new way of doing it and now like there's a lot of MMA
fighters that use this style now.
I mean it's different because they throw kicks and because takedowns are
incorporated into it.
A lot of what they call,
they call it neo footwork movements like Dominick Cruz is probably the best at
it.
He's the former bantamweight champion and Tj Dillashaw who's a current
bantamweight champion.
Both guys are great examples of people that use this kind of misdirection and
footwork like constantly left to right,
right to left.
But those guys also incorporates switching stances.
Like they'll fight southpaw and then orthodox and Orthodox south by,
they go back and forth.
I'll get this Ali just right in front of this dude and he can't do shit to him.
Um,
go to the knockout.
We see.
I don't know where,
where it is and this video,
it's can't be much further than this.
When's your next fight Joe?
The next UFC is next weekend is a big one too.
Chris Weidman versus Vitor Belfort.
Vegas.
Look at this.
Dang.
Oh son.
He stands over and when his hands up always.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He's,
that's real.
You see that's the way he's breathing.
Very different than the way Sonny Liston went down.
See that again?
Back it up again too.
There was,
I believe that he got knocked down twice.
I might,
I might be wrong.
Yeah,
he got knocked down twice.
So look,
this is dumb.
Yeah.
Back it up a little bit.
You can see the,
the flurry.
No,
it's three times.
He got knocked down three times.
Yeah.
And then eventually put away.
But he's just,
you know,
kept trying to chase him,
chase him,
pumping,
knocked him down,
walking away.
God Damn,
that was beautiful the way he did that.
Oh,
I,
I've watched his fight.
I don't know how many times is one of my favorite all time performances of any
boxer.
Just cause it would just to me like,
you know,
there's like certain Mike Tyson fights that did just the quintessential Mike
Tyson fight like Mike Tyson,
like,
uh,
like the one that when he won the title know,
like that was like a quintessential Tyson fight.
Um,
fuck is his name.
Fucking shit.
I don't remember his first flight.
I just remember him being the most terrorizing boxer I've ever seen.
I believe.
I can't remember this.
Um,
you know Joe,
when he was at his prime,
he used to fight.
He used to hit through the defense.
Oh yeah,
no,
he,
well,
he was just so God damn fast for a heavyweight.
There was,
nobody liked him.
There had been no heavyweights that were anything.
Trevor Berbick,
there was no,
no heavyweights that were even remotely,
I got a big lumbering guy too.
He just couldn't did,
he had nothing for Tyson.
You know,
Tyson at that time was just so fucking destructive.
He was so good.
But that like,
okay,
my Roz Frasier,
that's like the quintessential Tyson fight.
When I think of a Mike Tyson in his destructive to just,
just on point,
motivated in shape,
just so destroyer.
You seen them?
IRA's Frazier fight.
Oh that's the quintessential Mike Tyson fight for him.
Actually me too shouldn't have been in there.
He had no,
no business.
You know,
his dad was just as bad mother fucker and his dad wanted him to think that his
son was going to be the guy that beat Mike Tyson.
But you know,
you got to realize man that these guys,
like everybody that comes after you will have learned from everything you do
when your momentum,
we'll take them to another level.
And that's going to happen with every,
I mean there's lulls in sports fighting,
especially fighting,
especially as Lowell's I think basketball and football,
they all have lulls to whether you have like your superstars and then like
there's areas maybe where there's no,
no one that's consummate or no one,
no one is um,
like,
like the level of a a Jordan or a Kobe Bryant or Lebron James.
Like there's only a few guys that ever hit that like super,
super athlete level rose above the sport.
This is the first time in my life,
I couldn't name five boxes.
Really?
Yeah.
Right now
I could easily,
but it's,
it's a weird time for boxing for sure.
I remember,
remember when all those welterweights and when Duran and pet Carlos Palomino.
Oh yeah,
there was a bunch of guys.
Well you know what,
those are on ABC wide world of sports.
I don't know the heavy heavyweight champ.
Vladimir Klitschko say ya and Deontay wilder.
I think he has another one of the titles.
But the,
the thing about Vladimir Klitschkos,
he's just big Russian guy and you know,
you would think like a white guy that's the heavyweight champion.
This would be a crazy time.
Like everybody be excited to see him.
He's the most boring of all heavyweight champions,
possibly ever.
He's just very smart.
I mean,
not boring to me.
Um,
because I think he's got a very intelligent style.
I mean,
if you're six foot six,
the way he fights is the perfect way to fight.
He Jabs.
You had jabs,
you had drops her right hand and Clinches Jab,
Jab,
clinch,
right hand clench,
clench in with the Mayweather the other night.
Yeah,
I was actually looking at the time when the Moran left are so bored.
[inaudible] 54 [inaudible] shit.
I was watching it with my wife and she was yelling out like,
God,
this is so boring.
She,
she actually said this.
She goes,
you should have to get knocked down in order to win.
Well,
you should have to get and go with that.
That is the most ridiculous thing I've ever heard.
She goes,
well then it'll be exciting.
Like to someone who doesn't watch boxing,
like to see that,
that would be really boring.
It's the Kerry said something to me that I thought was interesting.
She said,
why don't they penalize the guy for holding too much for clinicians defending
yourself.
You're smart.
Yeah,
but I mean I liked it.
If they took points off for that then there wouldn't be as much clinching.
Well,
they put took points off at Klitschko in his last fight and it actually got kind
of interesting because Klitschko is,
you know,
he's famous for that.
He's famous for holding on to guys and he's a big fucking dude.
He's huge.
He's six foot six.
So he'll pop you and then grab a hold of you and wrestle you and put a lot of
weight on your neck.
You know,
like,
uh,
they,
they lean on you and put all,
make you carry their weight.
Like that's a famous way that guys will kind of try to SAP strength out of you.
It's essentially like they're trying to grapple with you and they took a point
away from him.
The referee was a,
just a real stern referee and then it forced him into some dangerous situations
where Klitschko was,
you know,
he was really getting threatened flying for the first time.
Like you've seen any of his fights for a long time,
but there's no one out there that's like a Tyson.
You know,
there's no,
like if you had a Lebron James,
like Lebron James became a boxer when he was young,
instead of became a a basketball player and it was just as dedicated to boxing
as he is to being a basketball player.
There's still some crucial elements.
You can be a great athlete in other sports,
but you wouldn't be a great fighter.
I mean,
you might be able to be a great baseball player or be a great basketball player,
but when it gets on the fighting,
there's some intangibles involved in fighting that don't exist in any other
sport.
You gotta be willing to go out there and risk your health and no one is there to
help you.
There's no one there to how you can't pass the ball.
You can't can't,
there's no timeouts you,
you,
you will go into the fire and you have to be able to,
you've gotta be able to hold yourself together under just a barrage of fucking
punches and the most dangerous guy in the world.
Who's your opponent?
Who's trained for eight weeks for this moment just to kick your ass?
I mean,
he's been not drinking,
not partying and sleeping all the time,
just so he can have more energy to fuck you up.
Well now there's the best athletes.
Don't go into boxing.
No,
we're baseball.
They go into football and basketball,
I think,
well even MMA,
you know,
we have a hard time finding the best athletes in MMA.
There's a few of them now that are just starting to leak into MMA.
Like guys who are like Olympic caliber wrestlers,
who are tremendous athletes that that Guy Silva was really good.
Anderson.
Yeah.
Anderson,
who's a very good fighter.
I mean,
he's the greatest of all time.
No,
but no doubt about it.
And he's a very good athlete.
But you know,
like a Jordan,
you know,
Anderson Silver was not Michael Jordan.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
he was a fantastic sight.
No,
well yes,
but he's suspended for quite awhile because he tested positive for steroids
after he broke his leg.
He broke his leg and fought again and won but tested positive for steroids.
Um,
but the um,
the difference I think is,
I mean there's no doubt that Anderson is a spectacular athlete,
the best MMA fighter of all time.
But I just think the level of competition that's involved in MMA or at least was
in his division now that division's fucking stacked with killers.
But when he was in his prime,
there was a long time,
we're like,
the title challengers were like Patrick Ota or Talis latus are these guys that
like really weren't at his level.
But now there's like seven or eight guys in the UFC middleweight division that
are just murderers.
So it's one of those things where a guy like Anderson,
who is the cream of the crop,
the best of the best,
pretty much the best ever.
And because he's at such a high level,
all those guys that are training,
it's see him and aspire to be him or aspire to beat him.
Those guys all come up in the gym and by the time Anderson's done,
when the new guy comes along,
Chris Weidman,
there's like this overwhelming momentum of competition behind him because all
these guys have been under the shadow of the greatest ever.
You know,
so it's,
it comes in waves.
I saw him do a WHO's losing the whole fight and then he got right at the end he
got a guy with a triangle.
His legs around his head.
Yeah.
Chael Sonnen tell,
didn't have to tap there either,
you know?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I don't know if jail was exhausted or if,
I don't know what happened.
Chell could've got out of that because that wasn't a fully locked in triangle.
People have gotten out of way tighter triangles,
but the fact is a bunch of factors that like,
one,
it was like chill,
kind of was susceptible to submissions and he was a psychological thing where
sometimes he would be winning a fight and he would just couldn't take the
pressure or something and we'd just get submitted.
But that fight in particular was weird because he was that close to winning the
fucking middleweight title man.
Was He close?
You're so close.
I mean,
he was a girl and when she was running away from it,
him running away with it,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
The fifth round.
And I'm [inaudible] to get caught in a triangle like that.
Like he didn't have to get caught in that triangle.
He could've played it smart and just held that guy down,
kept his posture and you know,
he,
he got caught and you know,
he tapped pretty much immediately.
And then he tried to like,
not say tamped.
It was like a lot of weird shit
that happened there.
Your career is amazing when you think about,
I told you my friend would get again,
got prosecuted the Sandusky.
Mm.
He said,
I think Brogan's the best announcer on,
uh,
in any sport right now in TV.
It does.
Very nice.
And,
uh,
I remember when I was complimenting you on stage live factory and he said,
I'm brand uncomfortable with this,
but I would love to do,
I would love for the people to see you.
It's doing stand up because you're so good at being serious with it.
If they ever saw your rack,
that would,
it would be explosive to them.
But you know,
I think people like to define people in one way.
Like you're either silly or serious or you know,
you read the sexy or you're goofy,
you know,
your whatever,
everybody wants to be defined in one way or another or it seems it's easier to
define people,
but we all have like various aspects to our personalities.
We all,
well I've weird,
subtle.
Yeah.
But we're all in line at the same like at a high level of both.
But it's just time.
You know,
just put a,
I put a lot of time in the doing standup
talent.
Joe,
don't,
don't turn away from it.
I mean it's like you don't,
you get a lot of people we've seen a lot of people put time in and they've got
worse.
Yeah,
but don't you think they're doing it wrong?
Like,
like,
like when they put time and like people put time in both blood and what are they
doing with that time?
Like how,
how much are they looking at themselves?
How on the bar?
I
just don't think they have certain gifts,
you know,
I mean I think like one of the things I,
I I study is,
is us stand up comedians and there are some people you couldn't see them walk on
stage.
They,
they're putting their bottle of water down and you know they're going to be
good.
They got an aura about them.
There's some people that are so just needy and
not natural and you know,
the not natural thing is tough because I don't know what you do about that.
No matter how hard you work,
just not a natural wit.
I was watching somebody last night and I don't want to name him,
name him dunked on there.
No,
I don't want,
I don't want to name it because I wouldn't want to hurt him.
But Chris Aaliyah,
no.
Crystal is in natural.
Brian Cowen,
Bradshaw,
I name all my friends I encountered should be out of the business.
He's a Shim is a man that mother fucker get over the years.
He's a poor man's.
You say,
let me tell you something.
There's no funnier guy for five days.
I'm thing try to love Brian.
Can I love Brian Couto he said,
well,
I go on hunting trips with him.
Five days of gay jokes and five relentless,
a nonstop hilarity.
Like he's just fucking never stops.
He's got that sophisticated size empty.
So field stage.
He's doing the Christopher Walken as a pigeon.
They had talked to them about,
uh,
this is a really fun Chateau Breo uh,
Chad Chateau,
Neuf de pop.
You know what I mean?
He's got all these like wines.
He knows and he knows a lot about why he knows where the grapes come from,
what part of the car.
And he studies that Shit.
I just felt weird.
I was close to the podcast last week.
I never heard from that just disappeared.
So him,
I told him no dub Dub David.
Oh,
so he's saying I,
you know,
he's my friend cause I love him,
but he's always late.
He's always,
you know,
but he is a character.
Oh he's,
but you can't be a guy like Brian count unless you're late,
unless you're flaky.
I mean that's one of the beautiful things of them,
but it's one of the reasons why I like hunting with him too.
He can't go anywhere.
I'm stuck with them for five days and we're hanging out in an island in Alaska.
I just,
Oh,
I could never do that.
We have so much fun.
I just watched an episode last night,
uh,
of us from the Prince of Wales island that I hadn't really watched a whole
episode before.
What's it on?
I lived to see it.
It's on the sportsmans channel,
which is like an all hunting channel and um,
it's called,
it's called meat eater.
And it's a Winnie and Cowen.
Yeah,
I'll send you a link to it.
I'll send you a link so you can watch it online.
Cool.
It's fucking great is he's so funny man.
I mean it's,
it's,
you don't get a sense of how really funny he is on the show because they show a
little of us goofing off,
but most of it's so inappropriate.
I,
you know,
he'd be like,
uh,
like we're to ready,
I'm gonna go kill some deer.
Tom,
you got a piece on,
Ya know?
And I like it.
All of a sudden it'll,
it'll like start,
he'll start talking about your cock for five minutes and it's one of those
things where it's,
it's funny and then you're like,
how long can you keep doing this?
Then it gets funnier and they like,
well,
surely this is gonna end soon.
Nope.
It gets funnier and funnier and then,
you know,
you'll see him an hour later and you can keep it warm for me.
I,
I just like,
it's just,
he's so ridiculous.
It goes out there with you besides you two.
Well,
this Steve Rinella who's the host of the show.
Um,
and then usually he brings either,
uh,
Ryan Callahan who was a,
another,
uh,
very experienced hunter and a guy runs his clothing company called first light
clothing company.
It's like a all hunting clothing company.
It's all Merino wool stuff.
It's kind of funny that like all these different,
you know,
synthetics,
all these different things that they've created for clothes and for,
you know,
for textiles,
wool,
Merino wool is still like the best shit at keeping you warm lamb's wool to
weird.
So,
um,
that guy,
uh,
Ryan Callahan come with us.
Yonis we tell us who's one of the other guides that,
uh,
that,
Rinella uses and you know,
we find a place to go.
Like we went Turkey hunting a couple of weeks ago that was up in Napa.
It was fucking crazy.
I think you told me that was great because we'd go Turkey hunting through the
day and then we'd go to like the best restaurants in the war.
I was thinking I would go there.
I would do that.
I wouldn't do the island thing.
Well,
Turkey hunting is easy too.
It's great.
Well,
maybe not easy for you.
Turkeys in nature.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
That sounds like such a stupid question.
It's a good question.
When the fuck do you ever see a wild Turkey?
I never in West Hollywood go to your apartment.
I don't see a wild Turkey on the way to your house.
See Pigeons,
um,
you sit,
you stick a rubber Turkey in the ground like a female Turkey and you've got to
hide because turkeys have really good eyesight.
So you were cam on a war,
like a Ghillie suit on my face.
And you know,
you're like completely tucked away behind this,
uh,
this Mesh Cammo background.
Like everything is like completely designed to,
to camouflage you from these birds and um,
minimal movement.
You can't move.
They see you moving the fucking bolt,
they're out of there and you put the rubber Turkey in the ground and got a bark,
bark,
make these weird hen Turkey noises.
They have all these different kinds of a Turkey call,
uh,
things that they use to try to generate the sound to call these fuckers in.
And then the Turkey comes in to check out the rubber Turkey and blast them.
They have to shoot him,
shoot him in the head,
shoot him in the head with a shotgun.
You save his body for food.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You shoot him in the body,
then you're going to be pecking pellets out of the body.
But I shot him.
Perfect.
Died instantly.
Get a Turkey.
There's a danger you missing and hitting the attack and yeah,
that's true.
That's true,
dear.
Oh fuck you up.
If everything goes wrong,
what is it?
The wild boar that so dangerous.
Oh,
they're definitely dangerous.
Wild pigs.
Yeah.
Wild boars have these big crazy tusks.
You know,
Doug,
Stan Hope told me that.
I didn't even know this.
Um,
Doug Stan hope told me that his next door neighbors dog got killed by Hava.
Lenas.
Do you know what a Hava Lean is?
This fucked up looking pig looking thing.
It's actually from a family called the peccary.
It looks like it's a pig.
Like it's,
you know,
like a distant cousin of a pig apparently.
Obviously I'm not a biologist,
but,
um,
there it is.
There's a Havalina,
those fucking evil conti looking things.
They killed his,
uh,
his neighbor's dog.
Like,
look at the tusks.
You see the teeth look up there.
Look at their fucking tusks.
Yeah,
they're freaky.
And I'm remember that joke Joe blow his fucking teeth.
Jesus.
Oof.
Hello.
Those lower fucking things.
What are we saying that joke about the uh,
Irish kid goes up to his father,
he says,
can I get $5 for Guinea pig as far as it goes?
Gets $10.
Get yourself a nice Irish girl.
People don't know a Guinea means.
It's a,
I soon as I heard the word pig guineas going out of style.
You don't hear that anymore.
It's definitely not on the west coast.
Not it was going on and the east coast.
You here?
Yeah,
I'm still here in best that.
I love you.
Yeah,
keep it.
It's okay.
Like we call each other guineas and it's all right.
Ins are very,
they're not thin skinned about names.
Now you grow up being abused constantly.
You know,
I never really know.
I mean the Irish are not,
not thin skinned either.
No.
Now.
Well,
you know,
they at one point in time where minorities immediately,
it's interesting when you watch,
there's a parallel to boxing because if you look at boxing in the United States,
it's always the immigrants that are the lower end of the social ladder where
they're really the best at boxing and they're fighting their way out.
It was Jews for a long time.
There's a lot of Jewish boxers.
You know,
that's one thing.
A lot of Jewish basketball players too.
Yeah,
I heard that her back and all know his generation before that.
that's interesting.
Well,
choose still our big basketball fans like PSAs Sussman's a huge basketball fan
as a lot of,
a lot of Jews in New York especially.
There's just love basketball.
Woody Allen sent every fight yet was 12 game.
Every game was daughter slash.
Wife.
You know that assessment story about Steve?
Steve Up.
Which one?
Steve Shrimp it,
you know it be for everybody.
He's on the Sopranos.
Terrific actor.
He was um,
back a law or something.
Richie,
is that what his name was on this promise?
I don't know.
He's a big guy.
Big Guy.
Really funny.
And he was working in Vegas at the time.
He,
before he was acting and you know,
Steve knew everybody in Vegas could get everything comped.
And I remember it's us instead of them.
Steve,
we're going to go to lake mead on Saturday.
Want to go?
He goes,
no,
I can't go,
but I can get,
I can copy a boat and to Jeff says to me,
who I'm fucking cop a boat shoe repair.
I forgot about that.
I remember that though now.
Yeah.
She ripple used to run before he became a big actor.
Uh,
on the soprano's he used to run the Riviera.
He was a talent booker at the Riviera,
which was the first place was,
it was hilarious.
He still is hilarious.
He's fucking hilarious dude.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
I'm going to get him on the podcast.
We've been trying to work out a date cause he's always writing books and shit.
He's always got something new coming out.
But I'd love that guy.
He's always been great too.
He's fucking hilarious guy.
Well,
he has no gray in him.
He either hates you and loves you.
Yeah,
that's it.
Uh,
he's an animal too.
I remember we were in the Riviera showroom and some guy threw a cigarette on the
ground and,
and,
and stepped on it like inside the showroom and he fucking screens this guy in
front of everybody.
You fucking moron.
Wait till you get to like this place on fire.
You stupid fuck,
pick it up.
Like,
like this is a guy who's,
you know,
up know patron,
right?
He's telling me you got to pick it up.
You know,
shrimp is enormous.
Giant,
too big.
And so the guy came over and picked it up and meagerly went back to his seat,
but he was,
um,
he was always this character,
like the really funny character.
And I believe drew Carey gave him his first break.
Like drew Carey put them in something like they were friends cause sure up he
used to book the Rib and then,
um,
like you could see like,
I feel like it was like the opening of one of drew Carey's comedy specials.
Maybe it was,
you know,
I had a pilot called dom time and it was like a sports talk show.
And Steve was my announcer.
I asked him to be my announcer,
and this was before I had any idea.
He was even interested in it because he had that voice.
Everybody.
And you know Tom,
I rare.
Why?
Yeah.
He's just a fucking character man.
Just such a character.
And then all of a sudden he's on the Sopranos and I was like,
whoa.
And he's fucking killing it.
I wouldn't really dramatic acting really good.
He's done great.
I had no experience.
Well,
he worked hard and he works with my friend Julian Beckton.
Remember Joanne?
She teaches acting and you know,
I remember reading,
reading the,
uh,
the size for the Sopranos with him in Montreal,
and he started to act.
And I remember saying them,
Steve,
don't act.
They want you.
This is what they want you,
or you're already a character.
You don't need to act like you know,
another Karen.
Just be yourself.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's cool when something like that happens.
I love seeing someone who just just take off.
Like all the sudden they're,
they're doing great.
I just love that.
I love.
See,
I love no one had guy when they're struggling and then seeing them when they're
awesome to that.
Some one of them the most pleasurable things to me.
Yeah.
There's certain guys that kind of everybody's happy for,
yeah.
Like Ray Romano when he,
sure.
And you know Billy Gardendale,
he's a great guy,
great guy.
And Billy,
his manager said,
you know,
you're so popular.
Even the bitter guys are happy for you.
Something like that.
It's true.
I never hear a bad word about Billy.
He's a great guy.
He's in a weird situation,
man,
because that Melissa McCarthy check that he's on that show with his fucking you,
Jeb.
And she's in every movie and she's just,
she's very hot,
but he takes it.
He enjoys it for him.
He's,
he's cool.
Oh No,
no doubt.
But I'm saying it's,
it's,
it's so weird.
They're like,
he's a really good stand up.
Yeah.
And it's a very good actor too.
For whatever reason.
Everybody's paying attention only to her.
I mean,
the whole show was kinda written right.
He's like the straight man for her wacky antics,
you know?
Yeah.
She's in a big movie now.
I feel bad for her.
Some sort of strange way.
I feel bad for her because she's so big.
You know,
I just like,
she jokes around about it and she talks about,
you know how she's having a great time and I imagine she is,
she's a huge star.
She's got to get a lot of joy out of a killing and like having people love her
and being so funny cause she's really fucking funny.
I mean she makes that,
that show really funny too.
She's really talented.
She's so big.
She's so big and just so unhealthy.
And I see all that extra meat honor.
Just holiday gelatinous it happened to be wiggling or you really,
no,
but I don't mind that.
And Larry will people be surprised.
I'm where was always done very well.
I don't know.
Do I did my best Joe,
whatever happened that comedy central show you did on football,
that was a great fucking show.
And I don't even like football.
It was,
it was,
it was ahead of its time in the sense that a comedy central wasn't as big then.
And frankly,
the show's ratings were good.
It was called off sides,
but I'll NFL,
the NFL is so fucking rich that they charge so much for the clips that it wasn't
worth it for comedy central really.
So that's,
that's why it died.
It didn't die.
A miserable,
unpopular death that was popular when it went down and they still cut a lot of
it into NFL films now.
So like I woke up the other morning,
I saw my face with a leather helmet on and the first thing I thought of was,
look how thin my face was.
Like I told you,
get that Gig,
the truck coming up in Lake City.
Um,
I'm going down,
I was in Philly at Thanksgiving and I'm going down to the shore and I see my
picture on a billboard and instead of going looking at him in a fucking kid from
Philly on a billboard,
I thought,
look,
I'll fucking thin my face was where did I get this fucking head fat.
You could lose it.
You just have to make a decision.
But I'm so hungry.
I understand.
But like the decision I made law,
I don't know.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
Eating healthy as tilt.
It's everything.
It's for me,
it's everything I went,
I like,
I'll go on a streak of like three or four days where,
and I don't eat that healthy and I feel,
I really do feel dull.
Like my mind feels dull.
The healthiest thing I eat is lean meat.
I didn't meet spray lt,
but I mean I really don't.
I Love Bacon.
I Love Bacon too.
I'm a huge fan of Bacon.
I love it.
I just think that you need moderation.
Well it's just,
I think you and I also,
we're both of very,
I think every comic essentially that we know of,
we're very indulgent.
I think that's a characteristic of comedians.
It's very,
very self indulgent,
very indulgent,
very impulsive.
Like comics,
like tend to do wild,
wacky things like you.
Like all of a sudden I'm in this fucking car and I'm hanging out with these
broads.
I'm,
Oh yeah.
Like that's the story that every comic has crazy wild,
were doing coke and drinking.
Every comic has some crazy indulgent story.
You know like you,
I'm setting my alarm clock for 6:00 PM so I can be at my show at eight.
You know what?
You have the best of both worlds cause you got a family life and that,
well I'm pretty disciplined but I could get indulgent what I've done.
I'm saying you go on the road and you have a good excuse to go on the road.
You're not going honey,
I'm going in a row just to fuck around for a real job,
for real money and,
but you have the luxury.
You don't have to get up and do morning radio now.
That's a big one for me.
I still have to do morning radio.
That's hard dates.
That's hard because a and people
who you pull a Boob,
you go to do Rodeo.
That what's the problem is it fucks with your sleep cycle and then that dulls
your brain to hey,
getting up at three in the morning.
Your time.
Yeah.
Hot Hang Doll.
My brain too.
If I'm hung over and I tried to go on stage,
I am just not as good.
I'd never seen her drunk.
I don't get that drunk.
I try not to.
I mean,
I've been a little lit up,
but,
um,
I've never been,
well,
I mean,
I'm certainly have in my day,
but,
uh,
I,
I just don't make a practice out of it.
I just am too aware of the consequences physically.
I do too much stuff with my body.
You know,
it'd be like if I had a really nice car and I would just like,
it'd be fun to Piss in that gas tank.
Well,
I know,
I know what's going to happen in the fucking car,
but you know,
I'd like a,
you know,
a shot and a beer,
but that's like kind of where it ends.
Maybe I'll have a third drink tonight.
Daily.
Gentlemen,
we're gonna have just sold out,
shoved down my reva,
but can you have a good time?
Fitzsimmons Ian Edwards,
is that the show you and myself or that going to have to show we're going to
have a good time.
The Greatest Club in the world,
that's the oldest comedy club on the earth.
Really?
[inaudible] the Ice House is the oldest comedy club in America,
and of course,
sorry,
everybody in the rest of the world,
but we invented this shit stand up comedies and American invention and the laugh
factory guarantees lives.
You see the difference by the,
I got a d you didn't laugh.
I laugh.
Sadi guaranteed for you.
How can you guarantee laughs?
That's ridiculous though.
Go your money back.
Dave Chappelle was on stage the other night at the comedy store.
It was very funny,
but he was doing this bit about a bad show that he had.
You know,
where people would be like,
you know,
God,
it must be so hard.
This is just recently.
Yeah,
he had a fucking terrible show in Canada on him and stuff.
Yeah.
He's had a couple of those because you know,
Dave's got kind of a slow pace and if he gets heckled or if you do,
people will heckle him and fuck with him.
Like sometimes it goes bad,
you know?
And it can go bad because he's so famous too.
It's like it becomes like this event that he's there.
It's not just that they do a real long the other night.
No,
no,
he did like he popped in,
I want to say he did like 20 minutes.
Wow.
But he fucking destroyed and he had the buddy of the bid about a bombing and he
goes,
he goes,
man,
it must be terrible.
What happens?
What happens when you get off stage?
I mean it's,
it must be awful.
Nothing happens.
Well it didn't work out.
I still get paid either way.
He goes,
I get paid for the attempt.
It was really funny.
It was.
It was fucking hilarious.
He did.
He had a joke about Floyd Mayweather too.
I don't know if this really happened,
but Whitney Cummings,
he said Whitney Cummings yelled out in the middle of the Floyd with his fight.
She stood up,
Floyd Mayweather beats women and he goes and men too bitch.
And he's laughing while he's doing it.
He's like such a jovial spoke was always smokes a lot of cigarettes.
They smoke so on stage,
right?
Oh he smokes a lot of cigarettes.
Smokes a lot of cigarettes and he believes a lot of conspiracies.
I believe he is one of the people that believes that bill Cosby was somehow set
up,
set up by 30 women.
I don't think he's,
I don't think he believes that bill Cosby didn't do it,
but I think that there's some folks out there,
I had an argument with a dude last night at the comedy store about this that
works for live nation,
a fine fellow,
not a bad human,
but he's made perhaps been hanging around with the wrong crowd.
And uh,
he said,
don't you think it's suspicious that it all happened like this?
Right.
When the show comes out,
I go,
he's fucking 70.
Okay.
He's had a career that's lasted since the 1960 [inaudible] he had a series in
the 1960s I spy,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
come on,
man.
No,
it's not a conspiracy.
That's cold weather.
Just trying to sabotage his career after a hundred fucking years at the top,
like it was for black man to get a series,
but it wasn't comedically about like a Stepin Fetchit type black guy and those
then,
well,
he was a,
he was a cop,
right?
Wasn't he?
He was a nice guy.
Yeah,
that's it.
That hurts me.
That one hurts me.
It really hurts me how my daughters too,
just that,
that I've heard it from people before.
Girls would tell you that they got roofing and it always,
it's always like,
it's always terrifying,
but somehow or another,
like the girl is telling you he's okay and the right in front of you and you go,
wow.
I was like,
it's hard for me to connect to this God.
It's awful and it's terrible.
But it's hard for me to connect to this.
Like I know it's real and I know it happens,
but when I heard that bill fucking Cosby was drugging and raping women,
allegedly,
I should say allegedly,
I can't make up that many stories are you could,
you certainly could Joe.
Three 30 you can get 30 crazy bitches,
but I don't think they are.
But they're not organized.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm just,
I'm not saying that they are,
I'm saying you certainly could if somebody,
somebody like some crazy bill gates type character wanting to pay 30 people to
come up with the same story,
they could certainly do all right.
Right.
I'm not saying that they did.
Yeah,
but I mean,
that's beside the point.
I mean,
I'm just trying to be as open minded as possible.
I'm not a denier in any way,
shape or form.
But what freaks me out is that this is a guy that was loved by fucking aliens,
millions and they loved him as this fatherly sweater wearing,
don't tell dirty jokes,
you know,
like that famous thing from the Eddie Murphy,
a special where he's,
you know,
getting mad at Eddie Murphy.
Richard Pryor tells him to not worry about it.
But apparently he did that to Katt Williams at that.
Really that with Chris Rock Rather.
That really bothered me the way he treated the young black guys that,
uh,
yeah,
because of their language.
And then you find out that he's a felon and unconvicted felon.
I mean,
yeah.
Well,
he's a rapist.
Let's say it right.
You know,
she,
when I first started,
I was on star search and he was the guest host and I heard shit about him.
Then same thing.
No,
no.
It just,
it just that it was,
you know,
he was married,
but he was a womanizer and I,
and like,
you know,
but there was something creepy about him even in those days.
So,
wow.
You know,
that's a long time ago.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's a big step between a womanizer and a rapist.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
The womanizers a guy who was an enthusiast who enjoys the lady,
seen Julie's the Bra.
It's sad,
but there's just,
there's a,
there's a lack of humanity in someone who's willing to drug a woman.
It's so fucking evil.
Like we were talking about rape and I was saying that there's no way I could
rape somebody because I have too much compassion and I could never hurt some.
Like I,
you know,
I know it sounds like you like,
oh,
big deal.
You couldn't rape somebody,
but I don't even fucking get it.
Like how you could be that evil and had to get hard seeing somebody cry and
stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm my,
I think in this podcast downloads.
Oh No,
you're not.
You know,
I think what we're talking about earlier about divas,
about this,
you know,
get out of my way.
I'm better than everyone else.
I think they're related because I think there's a,
there's a level of stardom that some people reach that gets,
the world gets very foggy.
Like obviously share is a very nice person and she's a very kind person to you
and very easy to get along,
but detached because of her fame and because of her popularity in,
well to the point where she feels alienated like nine,
10 she never knew what the real world it's right.
Yeah.
Sonny and Cher man.
Ah Fuck.
That's crazy.
If you think about it that way,
she's been famous for so long,
you kind of forget the thing.
But he,
and she was a big store.
That's nuts.
Chips is tramp sound.
Things can look good on that.
So I love that song,
but,
but it's in,
it's in tune,
but she's a nice person.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she made through that and stay at a nice person even though she's a quote
unquote diva,
she's a diva because she's extraordinarily talented and very respected and loved
and all that good stuff.
But that thing that makes you like everyone out of my way,
you know,
uh,
you know that whether it would Diana Ross did it and you saw the Whitney Houston
thing,
the body guards pushing it right side.
Yeah.
The Streisand thing that John Mellencamp,
he did John Mellencamp friend of mine,
uh,
Omar that not the tent maker in other Omar from the wire?
No,
he uh,
he was telling me that,
you know,
he was stage managing and you weren't allowed to talk to him.
He had to talk to his manager and he would say like right next to,
there's a guy like the blue collar,
pretty guy,
you know,
they didn't like him in Indiana.
I was in Indiana for a fight and they showed John Mellon camps picture in the
fucking whole crowd booed.
That's what I said and they said,
cause he's a liberal
because he's,
I don't know what he did or said.
I don't know what I don't know.
I don't know what it is,
but man,
there was like a bunch of booze and I couldn't believe it.
I was like,
this is John Mellencamp.
Like we're in Indianapolis.
He's from this area.
Yeah,
I was born in a small town,
you know,
that's him.
Like is that,
that's why I hit like a ball.
Them,
those women that were talked about,
I wasn't surprised by any of them,
but by John Mellencamp,
I thought he was like the gritty rammed earth.
Like Bruce Springsteen is notoriously personable.
Like have you talked to Bruce Springsteen?
Like Brian Cowen had a conversation with Bruce Springsteen and he said,
you talked to that guy and you would think that he's a fucking,
you know,
whatever.
He owns a company or he's a fucking banker or is it a normal dude?
He did,
but obviously charismatic and interesting and intelligent,
but he doesn't have any airs about them.
I was doing Conan.
I went and Bruce came up to visit Max.
The drummer into the,
their needs in the same group.
And uh,
I know you know that,
but,
uh,
he,
Bruce comes up to me and he says,
you know something about standup and,
and I said,
I guess he met if I ever open for anybody though.
Yes,
I have.
And I said,
you know what,
I would never ever open for you.
So I said,
what a fucking nightmare.
I said,
the curtain goes down and they're all going Bruce,
than the curtain comes up and I'm standing there with a mic and I go,
you're not Bruce.
We want Bruce,
whoever the fuck you are getaway.
Those are,
that's a hard thing when you're opening for somebody when they want the other
person.
That's a shitty thing to say too.
I've seen people open for other comics and you know,
bringing,
bring out,
you know,
tosh or bring out,
stabbed me on the bill.
So it wasn't like I was surprised I was on the bill.
I was one of the marquee.
That's big.
Yeah.
That's big different.
So people prepare,
they know you're part of the program.
Well,
you remember the whole bill birth thing,
the Philly thing?
Yeah.
You know that started with me.
You know that story?
Yeah.
Well those ONA crowds,
the past who I love,
but those guys are fucking notoriously mean.
They're notoriously mean if things go bad.
But the thing that happened was they were so drunk,
all they way with all they wonder was Jim Norton,
Jim Norton,
even he,
the only one that had a great set was bill,
because he'd be rated the fucking people.
And I even told them,
a couple of people booed me.
I says,
you know what?
Make a $12,000 for 10 minutes.
Go back to your mother's basements.
You fucking retard.
You're macerated Lazarus looks.
And then I got to cheer.
And Bill was still made.
It goes,
he says to me like,
I don't let him know on me.
He goes,
they booed dot Merera.
I go,
I am dumb or don't worry about it.
And I went on the speaker and I just sat there.
I was crying,
laughing and the funniest thing he said,
he put down everything,
the eagles,
the flyers,
the Liberty Bell,
the Liberty Bell fucked the Liberty Bowl.
Oh,
he's talking about how racist they are all the best boxers in the world.
You,
you fucking,
you go after a fictitious character.
She is white guy was five foot five.
You know what he said to me?
He said he had to stop doing them because people expected him to lay into them.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There was a,
that was a,
I was,
it was a point in time after that where like that became like what?
He was
known for you.
It could get mad.
You could go bad like that.
You could get stuck in a carer.
Yeah.
Like there's guys that are stuck in characters.
Oh yeah.
Like dice is stuck in a character.
Imagine being a 70 year old days.
I think he's funny.
I know you and him have problems.
I like them.
This one of my,
it just certain times in life you have friends that don't like each other.
That's just one of those days.
A friend.
I'm a way better friend of you tell you right now so that I am friends with
dice.
Right.
I like that.
As long as they're not easy,
but I love you like I love you too.
My brother right back,
I did.
Oh my friend,
but like you know,
he kind of became that guy for folks who don't know Andrew Silverstein was
Andrew Silverstein and Andrew Silverstein used to go on stage and used to have
a,
a variety of different impressions.
He used to do a tremendous,
John Travolta Travolta was actually,
he was actually,
he's an excellent actor.
Very good actor.
Very good impression as you do all these things and then he would do dice man.
Oh,
just all over it.
The Jews and the dice man character in his act,
you know that's from buddy love.
What's that buddy?
Love was in the nutty professor.
That's the characters to directly derivative from that.
Really?
Yeah.
He was doing either love in the nutty professor is that the 90 professor is
Jerry Lewis and like he takes a serum and changes to a different guy.
Well,
what do change it?
I need to see that any changes to that guy?
That's the character that dice became.
Really?
Huh?
Paul pudge.
Jamie in lieu illuminate the world.
Jerry Lewis,
nutty professor buddy love,
and it will be in Kilkenny in two weeks.
Are you going to go there?
Ireland.
Oh,
you son of a pet lover.
I've only performed a Dublin and Belfast,
Northern Ireland and,
Oh,
did you love it up into bell fed animals?
They call me the godfather of Kilkenny's.
Okay.
Find it.
But look,
he the way he looks.
So he became like a slick guy.
Is that what it is?
Well that,
yeah.
See if you can find something that way.
Hmm.
Jerry Lewis as buddy love tax man steak and all my Joe,
we've got a world that swings.
Whoa.
Oh my God.
It is.
Give me some volume here.
Wow.
He comes out as a cool guy with a cigarette in his hair slicked back.
Okay.
Wow.
Look at the people in the audience.
Back then chicken was beautiful
sleep fee and young and James [inaudible] and I've got,
oh well that's fine.
What
kind of bullshit is this?
This just shows you how culture evolves.
Have you ever seen the look how hot she is fucking googly Mooglie but they'll
let the broad on the leftover.
I going to cock block.
Jerry's going to try to make nice to her,
come over and say hi and the other one's going to drool all over him.
But yeah,
he is kind of like at a see the character,
the character.
I mean he's still seeing and find it.
He admitted that he was uh,
he was doing buddy low.
Really?
Yeah.
He never said that it was,
you know,
his,
his character.
I'm,
I'm almost positive on that.
Wow.
I did not know.
I never saw the was one of his many impressions.
I never even saw the g the Eddie Murphy version.
No,
I didn't see it as I,
so Jerry Lewis's,
I never saw it.
So that sit and listen and watch that old is load is wrong.
Got Sexy Lights.
How come back?
We were talking about this the other day.
How come nobody cared about girls asses back then?
Other credit goes tits.
There was no big assets back then.
Girls who aren't doing squats like you go to girls now they're all wearing
fucking yoga pay Melman rose as she couldn't even be one of the fly girls.
How about that?
Jayne Mansfield,
Marilyn Monroe,
those girls,
they,
I mean they had a different kind of body.
It was obviously very beautiful,
but they did not have like there's some ridiculous Instagram girls that have
like 2 million followers on Instagram and they have these giant butts.
Like look at Maryland and rose ass.
Get close up on that gym workout like women today.
That's what I'm saying.
Dom,
what happened?
I mean that's not a bad ass.
That's a very nice ass fuck Mount Moriah,
which certainly do that,
but it's a little on the flat side.
I'd have to look at her.
I'd have to flip her over.
I'd have to look her eye to eye,
which is fine with me.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong with this beautiful later,
best either,
but it's just there.
That's actually a pretty good sure.
Her back's arched up there on the upper left,
down,
right in the middle.
There you go.
Yeah.
But still like you compare that to like the style of body that women ascribed,
uh,
aspire to today.
I mean,
everyone was like the hourglass figure.
We'll do that.
The hourglass is very different shaped now.
Like you look at like the fucking Jennifer Lopez style asses,
you know,
I love her body.
Yeah.
I mean girls have just different assets now.
I mean,
and it's like Reince has evolved.
It has,
I mean,
girls never had asses like that.
This is like a big thing.
Like we want big muscular asses now where it's like,
if you look at like playboy from just a few years ago,
there was no girls that had big giant assets like that.
And it was,
it was,
it didn't exist.
This is a new fad diet.
I'd rather her ass be a little big than too small.
Oh,
definitely.
I like girls with a little body fat on them.
I think it's sexy.
Six sickest thing I've ever heard was a comedian friend of mine.
He goes,
Oh fuck shit.
She had such a nice,
it was like a little boy.
Scary
Pool.
Did you find any uh,
buddy love?
It's gotta exist.
It's the youtube,
the youtube has everything.
God dammit just found the full movies.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
Cut through that shit and get to the heart of the matter.
So in the nutty professor,
do you take like a potion and it became this cool guy?
Just real well,
it's here and Geeky stuff.
It's just weird.
The style of love movies and alive of entertainment.
Like when he was sitting there singing that terrible song in front of all those
people,
it's like people actually went to see something like that and they enjoyed it.
You know,
the world has changed in so many weird ways,
man.
So many weird ways that it's like,
it's,
it's hard to keep up with it or it's hard to,
uh,
to be,
to like put it into perspective and less.
He'd go back and watch old stuff.
Is this his character?
I haven't got it all
nice.
Yeah.
Here it is.
She's crazy about me.
Also.
No.
Last weekend jr you bought your drink about last night.
Tried to explain what happened.
I told you I was going to tell you it's a
why don't we kind of table it awhile sweetie?
Huh?
I mean all the kids that kind of waiting,
you know,
it's Dullsville out.
I'll be back.
You take five and I love it baby.
Madison.
Seely you wait for me,
Huh?
Oh there ya sweets.
Hello.
So all these girls come running up to the table and he's going to play the
piano.
He's drinking.
Huh?
Does this shot?
Got Something?
She's gorgeous and she find out what it is.
He's got something.
I think I'll do a
do a tour that I'm going to
record for a poverty records.
Sounds like Sinatra little.
Oh,
well he's,
his formula is wearing off,
right?
Isn't that what's supposed to be happening here?
He's like Mr. Cool Guy.
Not hilarious.
The idea that he can't continue to act like this.
It's impossible.
Not a stupid premise.
See,
it's coming out.
Go on.
Hi Laney Ribo flavoring hardware your near me.
Hi Amanda.
Uh,
what's happening?
Look,
she's turning to our friend.
What's happening?
Uh,
I think that'll be it for a while.
Kids that just get them run away.
Turned back into the professor,
the nerdy professor who can't get the girls.
Oh,
I like the girl on our wedding night who's absent minded.
Husband goes home to his mother for dinner.
Boy movie sucked back then.
Jesus Christ.
Could you imagine,
I mean that's almost like a parody of a movie.
Yeah.
I mean it's almost like a parody of you.
If you ever seen like some of the old stuff back when Liberace was a heartthrob
no.
Oh my God.
Pull up around Liberace winks at me.
This is one of my favorite things when I,
when I think about it like it was straight.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Forever.
For the longest time they would always ask him Liberace when you get to get
married.
Wow.
And just trying to find the right Gal.
But it's hard.
But you,
when you watch this,
when you watch like him and you realize when Liberace winks at me like this was
like crank this shit.
Like when guys that are gay,
when try and act like this,
this is a girl sitting at home.
She's writing like a fan letter and Liberace is on the TV
and watch when he winks,
it makes a crazy noise.
Like,
watch this.
Look at this.
[inaudible] hi [inaudible].
Hey,
you've got the other thing playing on the background,
Jamie.
Hold on.
Get it together,
bitch.
Hold on.
Pause it.
Don't go to your Twitter shine.
Jesus Christ you far.
Mayawati how dare you.
What have you done?
You've ruined this whole Liberace moment.
There we go.
Go back to it.
[inaudible] so natural.
Luckily [inaudible] get it.
Liver clinked putting blame links.
[inaudible]
that's what happens when Liberace winks at me.
Here comes,
listen to this,
the clean,
when he wins.
This is so weird.
I'm ready.
I mean,
okay,
you can kill it.
But I mean he didn't even sing.
You know this a,
is this the girl singing and his famous thing?
Let's play on the guitar or playing the piano.
Right,
but it was enough.
He,
that's all you needed.
He didn't,
I mean he sang in some other cities.
I don't remember saying right.
Didn't Liberace sing
somewhere over the rainbow?
He had to have sung man,
maybe it didn't.
I don't remember him saying it really.
That doesn't mean he didn't sing.
I wasn't a big fan drone or a huge fan.
I was a big fan.
Yeah,
the poster right next to the fair Fawcett poster.
But it's just,
it's weird when you look at old culture,
when you look at things that were just here he goes,
is he singing?
He singing deliberate hace show.
There's no,
no,
he's not.
He's not miked people who need people.
Oh,
he's talking to the song.
They're the luckiest people.
Oh,
kill that.
Kill that.
Before we go girl,
we can all turn gay just watching that,
that fucking documentary or that movie rather than he did about him for Hbo with
Matt Damon and um,
the Fox,
his name Kirk Douglas or Michael Douglas.
Michael Douglas in Jesus Christ.
That was good.
Did you ever see that?
Oh,
I heard it was really so good.
It's so good and so crazy.
Cause he's Liberace.
Douglas Douglas,
Michael Douglas Playing Matt Damon Played His boyfriend.
Oh God.
He's such a good actor.
He's so good actor.
But he had all this crazy plastic surgery to look like Liberace.
The boyfriend did in real life.
So they've got all this prosthetics on Matt Damon and make his Chin stick out.
And at the beginning of the film he's beautiful.
Matt Damon probably really looks,
but then as the film goes on,
yeah,
look at him.
He starts to get all of this plastic surgery.
Yeah.
See if they have it looks like a news.
Looks like Diane Sawyer.
Yeah,
I shouldn't say that.
It was really good.
It's really good cause I don't think it was too overblown.
I think it was really like fairly realistic,
much fun.
He had played in that,
I don't know if you're ready for Hollywood shuffle.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A gay friend of mine who I went to college with and that is,
then we just call him Vinnie the Benny.
And the reason I got the character was my wife and I were going down to their
college reunion and this is when he got gay or,
and Garrett,
cause he was a hairdresser on Broadway and he's really good dude.
He's driving me down and I go,
if any you want to be here,
he goes now,
thanks don.
But you have one that they did that little left,
whatever happened to Robert Townsend.
He's another one now.
That guy was a killer.
I remember he used to do those HBO specials.
We'd have all the different comics APP and yeah.
You know,
and he would like,
he had these elaborate sets and he was hosting it and he had all his movies.
Movie
was so funny with Damon and Keenan.
Wayne's and John Witherspoon and he had a bunch of good movies we had with Joe
when we shot that movie,
we were fucking crying,
laughing with someone happened to him.
Man,
I don't know.
Fuck.
You know,
he stole a bit of mine and that's how he got in the movie.
He remembered my school for Italians.
Yeah.
Is it a school?
I teach?
Italians had to be more Italian and he had a school for actors teach black
actors teaching black actors had to be more black.
Right.
So it's basically rip off and we're watching the Georgetown von over game at his
house and he tells me,
he shows me this thing.
And I said,
well Robert,
that's his,
you know,
he wanted me to do a part in the movie,
but he was also showing me,
you know,
just when you know,
I kind of borrowed some.
I said,
but that's mine,
you know.
I said,
you know,
not that it,
yeah,
I,
you even let them do it.
And he goes,
I never saw you.
It,
I go,
we worked together
every fucking night.
We did Improv on stage together.
How could you not see it with your mind?
Shut down.
It was wasn't in pair.
Yeah.
People will say that.
I've seen guys say that that work with guys and then steal a bit is that I never
saw you do it like bitch,
you saw him do it.
Some do it a hundred times.
Maybe.
That was a big thing at the laugh factory.
That was one of the reasons why I stopped going to the left isn't happening.
You should come back.
Oh by the way.
Yeah.
June 9th if you're available to,
is that,
it's a Tuesdays.
My next one.
Oh Man,
I'm in dumb.
I want to get the you and Joey.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Yeah,
no,
I'm good.
I'll go ahead.
Yeah.
The ninth I'll be uh,
um,
yeah,
I'm in Irvine that weekend.
Yeah.
I mean,
we'll get this with us.
Let's do it.
I loved the US do it.
Dia's was on fucking fire last night.
The funniest guy in the world ever.
He's the funniest guy of all time.
Fucking great.
Last night at the fucking Olr in the comedy store,
I was crying.
I mean,
tears were rolling down my hair,
my eyes rather.
Cause he,
does he say your whole name too?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Tom Or wherever.
Listen.
Dot My river.
I'll tell you right now,
these fucking bitches,
they got nothing for me.
Yeah.
He tells everybody.
He tells us everybody's full name.
How it's quite as dire guy like him peeking now.
I love it.
Love it.
Well,
you know,
I was the biggest Joey Diaz supporter of all time.
I was,
I would take him on the road.
Me when agents,
I used to have this old age and then fucking hated Joey and he would,
you know,
would say,
I just don't think the guy's talented.
I don't want,
you're taking him with me,
man.
You're out of your mind.
I go,
you're out of your mind.
I think you're,
I think this guy is holding you back.
I think it makes your show look bad.
Like please shut the fuck up.
You don't know what you're talking about.
Just stop.
Just stop talking.
And that guy has vanished.
Very generous you,
I mean you did it with Ari and B,
you know,
and I love those guys.
But I mean it was great that you had the power and the unselfishness to help
those guys careers.
Well,
one of the things about the comedy store where we all work on a regular basis,
we get to see guys who are good and guys were not good.
You know,
and our said to me once,
he like,
when you took me on the road,
I,
you know,
I wasn't funny.
I go,
that's not true.
You were funny.
You just weren't funny all the time.
But the times you were funny,
you were really fucking Nebraska Ju yeah it was.
He just,
he's a fucking great comic.
He just needed to develop,
I mean it's all it is,
but he had that ability.
But like,
I mean maybe it would be like two out of three bits would be killer and one of
them wouldn't be so hot,
but those two were fucking killing.
You know,
most comics are notoriously hard on themselves.
Like I'm very,
very self critical.
It's one of the reasons why I don't like compliments.
I'm just,
I'm always,
I dissect the shit out of my act,
but it's also one of the what?
What makes it good?
Cause I try to cut it out and trim the fat.
So that's like always opinion as well.
He was like looking himself like it wasn't good back then.
It was like just not true.
You will,
you had the ability to be very,
very funny.
It just didn't always work out.
It's because you were still learning to be a comic.
It's like guys,
I knew that,
I knew that about Dunkin.
I knew that about Diaz and I knew that about Ra because I saw them there all the
time.
I knew they had it.
They just had to do it.
I didn't know.
I mean I especially didn't know Dunkin cause he never mentioned it.
I would call it per spots.
He would take my spot.
Then we always had a good time.
Always like the kid,
he never even told me was a comedian.
Then all of a sudden he's doing it an x rated ventriloquist and then we'll do is
say tannic.
Ventral goes,
it's a little,
yeah,
little hobos.
Fucking awesome.
Somebody Stole Little Hobo.
He had to get a new little Hobo cod.
Fuck with steel.
You're pumping asshole.
I hope whoever you are you fuck.
I hope Liberal Little Hobo haunts you in your sleep.
Stole a little hoe about how rude.
Yeah,
he's a,
those guys are just,
but just,
you know,
I got to see them in the beginning.
You know,
I got to see them.
I got to see Dunkin like one of his first times ever on stage already.
Same thing.
I got to see Ari when he was essentially an open miker.
We became friends when he was an open miker and Diaz.
He had had a few years in his belt in Denver and in Seattle.
He had a few years,
but he was still putting it together,
but I just knew,
man,
I would just see,
I'd see those sparks,
those moments number when he was,
the voice were left for them with Lyft factory when they just plants his feet
just has that rant.
He destroyed the laugh factory two weeks ago.
It was a two weeks ago we did a show.
Oh,
he destroyed it,
but I'm telling you,
it wasn't like last night.
Last night I,
I don't want to say the bits that he was doing because they're all new bits.
I don't want to say what the premises where,
holy fuck.
We were crying.
There was like,
you know,
the audience was,
it was pretty good size,
you know,
and maybe a hundred people,
but all the comics in the back of the room,
we were just crying,
just crying.
I mean literally tears pouring down my eyes.
I watched this whole set and then went home.
And uh,
Adam,
you know,
Adam said,
it's so crazy,
like you've known that guy for so fucking long and you still laugh that hard and
you still go to CSS.
He's free,
he's free.
He's so free.
I remember he used to follow me at the lift at the comedy store,
so we had like a small friendship were always buddies and he used to get so
nervous.
Yeah.
And it was so different.
He was,
he really broke through.
But it shows you about this,
that doesn't happen.
The athletes you don't break through at 40,
50.
Yeah.
Right.
It's interesting because Joey's like 51 now I think,
or 52 and really never been better.
Never been better and didn't really catch for like maybe I just want to say like
five,
six years ago people started to know who he was and you know,
I could tell the difference when I would take them on the road,
I'll take them on the road.
Um,
and,
um,
people would like,
I would do a theater or something like that and Joey would go on stage and
people just wouldn't know who he was and they would start laughing after awhile,
but they would give a nice,
polite round of applause when he got on stage.
Now when Julie goes on stage,
I film it sometimes just to show people,
I put it on Youtube.
There's a video,
you could find it on youtube.
Find Joey Diaz going onstage.
It's,
it's fucking insane.
I think Joey Dee is going on stage in Denver.
One of the reasons why I did a theater in Denver was because Wendy had banned
Joey.
She,
she uses them now.
Like they,
they,
they smooth it over and he actually works at club now.
But he had some instance back in his old drug do using days where he's out of
his fucking mind and they banned him from the club,
you know,
common shit.
Richard Pryor's,
Sam Kinison got banned from the comedy store about a hundred times,
you know,
but um,
I know it was there.
Joey goes on stage and the fucking round of applause was so crazy.
I had a film,
right.
It was insane.
They knew who he was.
And this was like two years ago maybe,
I want to say.
So it was,
it was a few years in and he was just starting to realize that they had caught
on.
So for the longest time,
it's like I had been singing this guy's praises and nobody had,
nobody knew who the fuck he was.
They didn't,
they just didn't get it.
And then finally you find it.
It's Toronto.
I know.
It's not Toronto.
That's me.
Stop.
No,
that's not Joey Diaz.
That's Joe Rogan goes on.
Stays at Massey Hall.
You silly bitch.
It's not me,
Joe.
Joey can't even get to Toronto.
Trust me,
Joey.
You gotta say Joey Diaz goes on stage.
There's a,
there's a video,
son of a bitch.
How dare you.
He can't,
he can't get the Canada.
Yeah,
I know.
They won't let them in.
Yeah,
he told me I was,
uh,
I was trying to work with him somewhere.
Armed kidnapping.
Yeah.
Bring somebody into another room.
Kidnapping and armed robbery had a machine gun.
He stole coke from somebody to,
they really,
we know we sometimes we,
we split the bill at the Ice House.
Him and I'm,
yeah.
Yeah.
Those are great.
Shows.
Fun.
I told you what he said to me the first time we did it.
I said,
Joe,
whatever you want to do,
want to go on for a second interview?
He goes,
I'll tell you what though,
Maria,
why don't you go to the first show and going first to go close the first show
close second so you don't have to follow a pig like me that late.
They get,
and then you go to,
you can go to the laugh factory down the set that only you could make you give
me the easy spots,
but you're right in my itinerary.
He's a character.
There was,
nobody liked that guy.
You know?
I think we're,
we're very lucky.
All of us are just so we know each other.
I feel very lucky that I know you all right.
Yeah,
I mean,
I enjoyed that moment we had with me,
you and him at the comedy store in the,
in the parking lot.
Yeah.
I just,
it's just fun and relaxing and,
well,
you know,
Brian Cowen was telling him was talking about this the other night because his
wife made him go on some fucking horrendous double date and he's like,
he's hanging out with this guy who was just apparently really obnoxious and
annoying and he's,
you know,
and his wife was like,
I thought they were fine.
He goes,
do you understand that I could be right now at the comedy store hanging out with
the funniest people on earth and I'm hanging out with this idiot who wants to,
you know,
Brag about his boat or whatever the fuck you talking about some blowhard.
So what's it like to bomb?
That must really be something.
I must be,
I didn't believe her rescue that.
Yeah,
I get that.
It's like,
what's it like to buy it?
That's how much you think I fucking bomb.
If I work all over the world,
we're going to get done rear over here in New Zealand.
I always say it's like sucking a thousand Dick's in front of your mother.
That's the best way to describe it.
But the problem is that that kind of time maybe that's a lot.
It was.
What'd you be?
Real card.
I'm not saying to climax.
You know you can get through 10 in a short period of time.
If you got a good head.
Got Good head movement.
Um,
we got to get out of here.
You're a car is supposed to be picking you up right now.
This motherfucker,
the anger at the Tropicana next that there 23rd at Atlantic city.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's dumb.
I rare his hood right next up.
Powerful.
Philadelphia.
Joseph.
Thank you.
Always good man.
Yeah,
we're going to have fun.
We're at the ice house sold out tonight.
Sorry bitches.
A boat would probably be doing another show next Wednesday night too.
Cause I've got a big Vegas show next Friday.
Got Out plucking.
Tune up.
Oh
Hey,
I love you brother.
Love you too man.
All Right Ladies Gentlemen.
We'll be back tomorrow with Adam score g,
the producer of the union and the culture high,
and he'll be here tomorrow.
Thank you.
That's fine.